[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est l'événement sur Public
Sénat une édition spécial que l'on vous
propose pour vivre en direct le vote du
texte immigration au Sénat à partir de
19h et puis à l'Assemblée
ensuite d'ailleurs notre décor et bleu
blanc rouge c'est vraiment le décor des
soirées événementielles sur sur
l'antenne et et vous aurez alors je suis
pas habitué derrière moi c'est
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
donc ça va se jouer là et et je suis pas
habitué hein ça va se jouer là aussi
évidemment beaucoup ce soir beaucoup de
questions puisque le gouvernement et les
LR sont parvenus à un accord sur ce
texte la CMP la commission mixte
paritaire et donc conclusive c'est le
terme qu'on qu'on emploie mais à quel
prix la majorité présidentielle déjà
fragile peut-elle exploser ce soir les
députés modem les élus le de l'aile
gauche de la macronie vont-ils voter
c'est avec le rassemblement national et
puis Emmanuel Macron qui a promis vous
le savez un rendez-vous à la nation au
mois de janvier peut-il ouvrir un pour
pour de bon cette fois-ci un nouveau
chapitre de ce second quinena on
répondra à ces questions on a 1 heure
devant nous jusqu au début du vote ici
au Sénat avec nos invités mais d'abord
ce que contient la loi immigration dans
sa toute dernière version avec Samia de
chia il aura fallu plus de 24 heures
pour y arriver la majorité
présidentielle et la droite ont
finalement trouvé un accord sur le
projet de loi immigration à la demande
de la droite les conditions de
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers danst les métiers en tenstion
ont été durcis ils devront entre autres
justifier d'un casier judiciaire vierge
et prouver leur respect des valeurs de
la République nous avons mis un échec un
texte qui était impuissant et inutile
voire qu'il y avait des côtés dangereux
sur la régularisation des clandestins
pour promouvoir un texte responsable
avec de vraies dispositions qui sont de
nature à infléchir la politique
migratoire autre point d'accord sur les
aides au logement pour y avoir droit les
étrangers qui travaillent devront
justifier de 3 mois de présence en
France et de 5 ans pour ceux qui n'ont
pas d'emploi une forme de préférence
nationale dénonce la gauche qui accuse
la droite et l'exécutive de faire
triompher le programme du rassemblement
nationale la CMP est conclusive elle est
conclusive dans le déshonneur pour la
droite qui finalement a été l'idiot
utile du RN de fait le RN jubile Marine
Le Pen revendique une victoire
idéologique et appelle à voter cette
nouvelle version du projet de loi
immigration cette loi devient une loi de
durcissement des conditions de
l'immigration nous allons donc
voter cette ce texte tel qu'
ressort de la commission mixte paritaire
un soutien très embarrassant pour la
majorité
présidentiel plusieurs députés
macronistes de gauche ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils refuseraient de voter le texte au
côté du rassemblement national mais
l'exécutif ass sur pouvoir compter sur
les voies de la droite et du centre les
républicains la moitié du groupe yach et
la majorité dans son ensemble qui est
donc favorable à l'accord puisque nous
avons réuni nos groupes et qu'il y a eu
des expressions on n pas besoin des voix
du rassemblement national la nouvelle
version du projet de loi immigration
sera examinée au Sénat aujourd'hui à 19h
puis à l'Assemblée nationale à
21h et on va se compter au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est l'un des
enjeux de cette soirée on vous fait
vivre en direct à la fois les réactions
des personnalités on sera euh dans les
différents lieux où où se joue euh cette
cette soirée tiens toute dernière
nouvelle on l'a pris il y a quelques
minutes Emmanuel Macron a convoqué euh à
18h donc c'est en ce moment une réunion
avec sa majorité parlementaire au sujet
de ce projet de loi je je je cite
l'Agence France Presse le président fait
un point de situation avec la première
ministre les présidents de groupe et les
chefs de partis de la majorité je vous
présente tout de suite euh mes invités
Pascal Perino bonsoir Pascal bienvenue
politologue professeur à Sciences Po
Paris Émilie zapalski bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes communicante
fondatrice de l'agence Émilie conseil
Erwan lestran bonsoir et bienvenue à
vous aussi directeur conseil à l'Intitut
de sond
odxa laticia crupa éditorialiste
politique bonsoir latia bienvenue à vous
et puis en duplexe avec nous de de la
salle des conférences ici au Sénat
Quentin calm bonsoir Quentin vous
n'hésiterez pas évidemment à à à nous
faire signe dès que vous avez des des
invités puis pour faire un un point sur
sur ce qui se joue on reparlera
peut-être de la forme Pascal Perino mais
sur le le fond sur le contenu de la loi
quelle leçon vous tirez de cette
commission mixte
paritaire écoutez comme la plupart du
temps la commission mixte paritaire a
fait son métier c'est-à-dire elle est
arrivée à un accord à concilier des avis
divergents dans la majorité des cas
lorsqu'il y a une commission mixte
paritaire ça débouche en effet sur un
compromis parce qu'on est dans un petit
cercle et c'est plus aisé de faire dans
l'intimité de la commission mixte
paritaire un accord que dans le le Chahu
sur le fond c'est un compromis ou c'est
un texte qui penche clairement vers ce
que souhaitait lesr NOTAM
sur l non pour les LR c'est une victoire
parce que ils ont largement imposé toute
une série de thématiques vis-à-vis
desquelles la majorité au début du
processus était rétiscente mais que
voulez-vous alors on est en France c'est
vrai je sais que le compromis c'est
quelque chose qui est très difficile à
imaginer pour les Français qui soit de
gauche de droite ou d'ailleurs dans un
compromis il faut un peu faire un bout
de chemin on n'est pas sur les mêmes
positions et là en effet Gérald Dar
avait essayé mais ça avait suscité des
hostilités du côté d' l'air parce que
c'était un ancien LR et là on voit que
une fois géraldde dararman a sorti du
champ et bien ils sont arrivés à une
situation de compromis dans lequel il y
a une victoire de LR et derrière en
effet un Ren qui une fois de plus se
réjouit en disant bah voilà toute une
partie de nos idées ont été reprises
mais ATT c'est pas la première fois que
le RN vote à texte de la majorité alors
avec effectivement et on va on va en
parler des des risques de fragmentation
à court terme c'est sûr mais peut-être
aussi à moyen et plus long terme de
cette majorité présidentielle Milie
zapalski c'est vers le Sénat je rappelle
19h ensuite Assemblée nationale 21h30 ça
c'est le calendrier des votes ce soir
est-ce que vous diriez pour ellisabeth
borne sûrement mais peut-être aussi pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est une sorte d'heure
de vérité ce soir euh une heure de
vérité mais aussi peut-être un
éclaircissement sur justement ce en même
temps qui penchait de plus en plus à
droite et là qui clairement euh penche
complètement à droite avec même donc des
idées reprises ou en tout cas qui
ressemble beaucoup au rassemblement
national moi il me semble que c'est un
éclaircissement et c'est assez
intéressant parce que on voit on a
l'impression ça pas dire qu'Emmanuel
Macron d'un seul coup euh est proch de
Marine Le Pen politiquement voyz ce que
je veux dire c'est une belle opération
je trouve que c'est une belle opération
de communication qu'il leur transmettent
euh au rassemblement national et on
entend depuis hier hein presque mais
surtout depuis ce matin euh voilà ils
ont choisi la préférence nationale ce
qui était dans notre programme le
rassemblement national et ils se félicit
de tout ça c'est un peu comme au
rencontre de Saint-Denis c'est s'est
déroulé un tapis rouge quand même une
espèce d'opération de communication très
réussie pour le rassemblement national
alors qu'à la base Emmanuel Macron et je
reviens à son élection était là
justement pour faire rempart au
rassemblement national on a entendu très
rapidement c'est le scénario qu'il avait
écrit pour gagner face à Mar mais on a
entendu on a entendu un Géral Darmanin
récemment dimanche qui a dit si on ne
fait pas ça ce texte qui ressemble
beaucoup à RN c'est Marine Le Pen qui
est élu donc c'est une drôle de c'est un
drôle une drôle de façon d'éviter le RN
tout en utilisant les méthodes du
rassemblement national juste pour dire
ce qui est intéressant c'est que on a
l'impression que ça fait réapparaître le
clivage gauche- droite au au sein même
de la majorité puisque moi je pensais
pas qui qui av des rebelles comme Sacha
Houlier qui qui annoncent qu'ils
voteront contre le texte même si
probablement ça changera rien au vote
euh je pensais qu'ils allaient voilà
plutôt rentrer dans le et on a
l'impression que ça réveille les uns et
les autres même au-delà de la majorité à
gauche parce que quand même c'est un
texte qui qui qui fait un pas de plus
vis-à-vis des étrangers c'est un peu
particulier ouis on va détailler dans un
instant grâce à Quentin calmer un peu
l'état d'esprit des des
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle euh herwan lestran c'est
euh est-ce qu'elle peut imploser ce soir
cette majorité déjà fragile non
probablement pas mais en tout cas la
conclusion peut-être de ces derniers
jours c'est que l'immigration n'est pas
soluble dans le en même temps au même
titre que la sécurité c'est vrai qu'on
aurait pu l'observer mais ça ça ne
marche pas dans le en même temps vous le
disiez et c'est vrai ça réinstalle
complètementage Gao davantage marché
hein non plus mais mais on voit que le
sur ces sujet là le clivage gauche-
droite se réinstalle complètement on l'a
aussi sur les questions de sécurité
aujourd'hui sur la stratégie la victoire
va plutôt à au Républicain sur
l'idéologie plutôt au RN mais mais en
tout cas le l'enjeu pour la majorité
aujourd'hui c'est probablement soit de
rester uni soit de limiter l'existence
de frondur en interne on avit vu comme
ils avaient sapé le quinquena de de
François Hollande c'est ce serait bien
pour Emmanuel Macron de minimiser le
poids des frondeurs dans son mouvement
après un an de mandat oui et puis signe
de ces tension je vous le rappelle
réunion de la majorité en ce moment même
à l'Élysée a tour du président de la
République Quentin calm vous êtes donc
en en salle des conférences ici au au
Sénat vous vous avez vous suivez hein
cette commission mixte paritaire depuis
hier pour pour Public Sénat dans dans
quel vous avez peu dormi hein merci de
de de tenir la baraque comme ça voilà
c'est aussi ça le métier de journaliste
dans quel estat d'esprit sont les
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle que vous avez croisé ces
dernières heures effectivement Thomas on
était aux quatre colonnes à l'Assemblée
nationale on a r trouver le décor
traditionnel de public scénat la salle
des conférences effectivement c'estes
dorure et la moquette rouge
effectivement auquel on est habitué mais
effectivement à l'Assemblée nationale on
a vu dès 40 minutes avant la fumée
blanche et l'accord de la Commission
mixte paritaire des députés renaissan
assez mal à l'aise quand les
journalistes leur posaient des questions
en salle des quatre colonnes et parce
que par exemple Sylvain Maillard le chef
de fil des députés Renaissance il est
passé assez blême on peut le dire en
disant juste un laconique il va manquer
quelques voix à la majorité et là
effectivement depuis l'annonce de
l'accord de la CMP 17h 30 on voit des
députés modem ou Renaissance donner leur
position à titre personnel comme et bien
Jean-Paul mati le président du groupe
modem qui pourrait emporter avec lui
plusieurs députés modem et qui a annoncé
qu'il allait voter contre l'accord de la
CMP même ch même chose pour Sacha
aoulier un personnage emblématique le
président de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale il est Renaissance
c'est lui qui dirigeait les travaux de
la CMP il a annoncé qu'il allait voter
contre un autre député Renaissance
appelé ses collègues Renaissance qui
hésitai et bien à cause de la rédaction
trop à droite de l'accord de la CMP il
les appelé à s'abstenir plutôt qu'à
voter contre lors de nos échanges en
salle des quatre colonnes tout à l'heure
Renaissance qui espère ainsi profiter
des 62 voix DLR grâce à l'abstention de
à cause de l'abstention de certains de
leurs collègues Renaissance quandant au
fait que le rassemblement national
appelle à voter le texte ces députés
Renaissance ils étaient clairement gên
né ils nous ont dit on n'a jamais compté
sur les voies du rassemblement national
ils font aujourd'hui un coup politique
une manière de se rassurer avec nous
même s'ils étaient effectivement très
embarrassés devant la presse Thomas
merci Quentin encore une fois n'hésitez
pas si vous avez des des invités à faire
intervenir en direct ou pour nous livrer
d'autres informations à nous faire signe
autrre information livrées par nos
confrères de l'Agence France Presse avec
cette expression baiser de la mort
employé par un député renaissance
macroniste de la première heure pour
qualifier final
ce choix du rassemblement national de
voter le texte et d'obliger les députés
raissance au MoDem à se positionner
l'une des première d'ailleurs à avoir
pris la parole après le l'annonce d'e de
cette commission mixte paritaire
conclusive c'est Marine Le Pen qui
annonce que donc le le le vote du parti
on l'a entendu déjà dans le sujet de
Samia dechir alors je vous propose de
remonter quelques heures plus tôt
Jordane Bardella qui parlait déjà de
victoire idéologique écoutons la
victoire idéologique du rassemblement
national est de plus en plus forte
chaque jour
on est passé d'un texte que nous avons
mis en échec à l'Assemblée nationale qui
prévoyait des mesures d'accélération de
l'immigration avec cette cette ouverture
d'une nouvelle filière d'immigration via
la régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier qui constitue en soi une prime à
l'illégalité un texte durci sur les
conditions d'octroit des aides sociales
notamment aux étrangers sur le
rétablissement du délit de séjour
irrégulier mon analyse c'est qu'on a là
la conséquence concrète du rassemblement
national à 30 % dans les sondages et
donc dans dans quelques heures la loi va
peut-être passer à
l'Assemblée Pascal Perino grâce aux voix
du rassemblement national c'est c'est
quand même un affront pour pour éabe B
c'est pas évident qu'ils aient besoin
des voix du du rassemblement national le
rassemblement national votera parce que
il va pas se priver de ce
plaisir mais voilà il pourra y avoir une
majorité sans forcément l'apport des
députés des députés du Front national
mais surtout là on est tout t délice des
prises de position des partis des
députés des sénateurs et cetera mais
enfin euh une majorité elle doit
représenter la majorité du pays or que
constate--on depuis des semaines et des
semaines l'Institut odoxa l'a fait
d'autres instituts comme laabé l'ont
fait ils ont pris toutes les mesures
dans du du projet de loi et ils ont
demandé aux Français ce qu'ils en
pensaient sur toutes les mesures à peu
près sans aucune exception les français
a des majorités fortes sont d'accord
avec un durcissement oui ce qu'il faut
appeler un durcissement des conditions
ils étaient aussi d'accord avec
l'article 3 si je me même les
sympath% donc l'équilibre plaisait aussi
au français bre voilà non mais en fait
globalement si vous voulez les Français
il y a plus de à peu près 2 tiers des
Français qui disent qu'il y a trop
d'immigrés en France voyez on voit bien
qu'il y a une droitisation sur ce thème
qui est une droitisation sensible qui
touche pas simplement l'électorat de la
DR drite l'électorat du rassemblement
national mais aussi l'électorat de la
majorité et l'électorat de la gauche
jusqu'aux électorats et les filles 40 %
des électeurs des sympathisants des
lesfi disent qu'il y a trop d'immigrés
en France voyez
donc quand on parle de la représentation
est-ce que c'est une victoire
idéologique du rassemblement national
pour reprendre les mots de Jordan
Bardella oui parce que certaines mesures
sont des mesures qui sont des mesures
que le rassemblement national préconise
depuis longtemps mais il y a d'autres
mesures que LR préconisait que le modem
avait pu préconiser que Renaissance
avait préconisé d'acc Émilie P qui
voulez intervenir il y a il y a ces mots
qui qui sont employés notamment par la
gauche pour finalement euh qualifier ce
qui s'est passé au sein de cette
commission mixte paritaire qui
reviennent sur les mot préférence
nationale est-ce que cette loi dans sa
dernière version est imprégnée
finalement de la préférence nationale
telle qu'elle est pensée par le
rassemblement national ou le Front
national auparavant DEP Ann remblement
National veut marquer cette loi alors on
entend ici est-ce qu'on tombe pas dans
le piège du Aren quand finalement on
reprend cette rétorique c'est ce qu'a
dit Gérald harmanin en disant attention
c'est déjà ce qui est le cas pour le RSA
par exemple que les étrangers ne le
touchent pas tout de suite qu'il faut un
délai de 5 ans donc ça existe déjà mais
quand même c'est des pas supplémentaires
moi je reviens juste sur cette
droitisation de la population française
il faut regarder quand même dans la
nuance tout ce qui est dit oui demande
plus de fermeté et on peut le comprendre
avec tout ce qu'on vit notamment en
terme de terrorisme de qtf d'obligation
quitter le territoire français qui sont
pas respectés pas appliqués je suis pas
sûr que la loi va permettre plus
d'application de ce côté-là parce que ça
dépend pas de nous ça dépend de
l'international donc les Français oui
demandent plus de fermeté mais comme
vous l'avez dit ils étaient aussi
d'accord sur cet article 3 de
régularisation des S papiers pour des
métiers en tension ce qui a été
fortement durci dans une version les
républicains où il y a plein de
contraintes particulières l'article
enfin le le la mesure reste mais dans
une ver version d'ailleurs qui va que
jusqu'à fin 2026 si j'en crois ce qui
ressort du texte qui sera établi de la
CMP enfin du texte de la CMP donc
quelque chose qui est un petit peu
raboug gris par rapport donc je suis pas
sûr que les Français oui ils ont cette
envie et quand on les questionne ils ont
envie de plus de fermeté mais ils ont
aussi cette ouverture qui est un peu la
philosophie de la France d'accueil de
régularisation de personnes qui en plus
nous servent parce que c'est des métiers
qu'on fera pas donc je pense que c'est
un petit peu plus nuancé moi ce que je
trouve c'est que là le texte oui
ouvertement il passe un cran au-dessus
et puis surtout il a libéré beaucoup de
paroles très décomplexées et c'est là je
trouve que c'est grave ça fait un an et
demi he que Gérald harmanin se traînait
ce projet de loi qui a eu des
discussions est-ce qu'on le fait en
saucisson pour faire passer à gauche à
droite parce qu'on voit bien le mal
qu'ils ont eu pour le faire passer si si
s'ils arrivent au bout euh pendant tout
ce temps-là oui les paroles ont été très
décomplexées et on sait qu'on entend
souvent plutôt ceux qui crient fort et
ceux qui sont radicaux dans tout ça et
ça crée dans la société il me semble une
une parole très décomplexée mais ça veut
pas dire que c'est le reflet de tout ce
que pensent les Français on va voir et
on voit déjà la dans la majorité que ça
grince des dents justement par ce côté
jusqu'au bouthist un petit peu des
mesures un petit peu plus fermes on va
voir si dans la société française on a
vu déjà un des manifestation contre ce
texte arrivé on va voir comment ça se
passe her ces termes préféren nationales
ils sont clairement associé au au Front
national d'abord enfin au Le Pen pfille
pour ou tout à fait tout à fait même au
FN plutôt qu'au qu'au RN mais en tout
cas c'est c'est de la préférence pour la
présence sur le territoire national
aujourd'hui plutôt que de la préférence
nationale mais c'est vrai que ça y
ressemble mais et je rebondis sur ce que
disait Pascal Pino il y a un contexte
d'opinion que les députés les sénateurs
ne doivent pas ignorer on a 6 Français
sur 10 aujourd'hui qui considèrent qu'on
évolue vers trop d'assistana qui
considèreent qu'il y a trop d'étrangers
en France on voit le soutien au droits
d'asile qui a tendance à reculer dans la
population on a 7 Français sur 10 qui
juge que la politique en matière
d'immigration est trop laxiste donc voir
des Français qui préfèrent un projet
privilégiant un contrôle durci de
l'immigration plutôt qu'améliorer
l'intégration des étrangers c'est assez
logique dans le contexte actuel la
semaine dernière on interrogéit les
Français au sortir du vote de la motion
de rejet il y en a uniquement 3/1 qui
souhaitaent un abandon du projet et
parmi les 7/1 qui voulaient un projet il
voulaient majoritairement un projet qui
penche à droite proche de celui des des
sénateurs donc ça va plutôt dans le sens
des Français et c'est vrai que il y a
peut-être un risque pour les
parlementaires à apparaître hors sol par
rapport à ces préoccupations dans un
contexte qui plusit d'actualité qui fait
remonter les préoccupations sur la
sécurité et sur l'immigration qui sont
revenu à un haut niveau dans la
population qui sont des thématiques
l'immigration et la sécurité très
sensible à l'ctualité il semble quand
même que on on réduise le champ
d'analyse pardon hein je sais que c'est
efficace à des moments té au sondage il
faut regarder où on votter les Français
on n'arrête pas de dire la France est à
droit depuis 2022 il faut regarder les
élections on est encore en démocratie
représentative pour l'instant
excusez-moi c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
est
passé je vous rappelle la candidate de
la droite moins de 5 % 62 députés la
France à l'heure où on se parle n'est
pas à droite donc on verra 2027 en fait
c'est ça qui qui est un petit peu
particulier soit le
gouvernement finalement voulait un texte
plus dur soit il a flanché pour
justement un parti qui a pesé en 2022
moins de 5 % que finalement c'est c'est
ça qui c'est ça qui est difficile à
comprendre y a il y a une logique
parlementaire qui qui est l'incapacité à
faire passer des des des texes même s'il
y a beaucoup de lois qui ont été voté
parfois avec des députés de gauche qui
les votaient parfois avec des députés de
droite mais dès qu'un texte on l'a déjà
dit ici prend toute la lumière
médiatique là ça devient beaucoup plus
compliqué de trou une majorité on VO
bien c'est terrible parce que le la
réforme des retraites les Français y
étaient majoritairement opposés on a eu
le 493 pour la faire passer là vous le
dites dans les sondages les Français
étaient majoritairement pour un un texte
plus ferme et et on en arrive au bout du
bout à voir la copie DLR enfin le
gouvernement aurait pu peut-être aller
jusqu'à ça et peut-être même imposer un
493 puisque ça allait dans le sens des
Français vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est que là on a l'impression qu'ils
ont pris la copie des républicains qui
ne pesaient en effet en 2022 pas
grand-chose alors que ça va dans le sens
des Français c'est pas très cohérent ou
on est en démocratie représentative les
républain expliquer pourquoi il a cette
drtisation alors que c'était pas l'objet
du texte pas tous en même temps si si
moi je je rajoute on est trop à parler
en même temps personne n'entend rien au
français aux électeurs mais aux Français
comment LR a pesé autant dans la balance
alors que je vous rappelle que c'était
moins de 5 % mais oui mais c'est c'est
aussi une majorité avec avec les
centristes II au Sénat on va pas oui
mais ça c'est réel ça c'est la majorité
ici au Sénat elle pèse aussi voilà je
voudrais je vous donne la parole tout de
suite Pascal Perino qu'on qu'on entende
justement puisqueil y a cette critique
voir cette accusation d'un
amalgame du gouvernement avec l'extrême
droite la première ministre c'est cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée a répondu elle
s'est défendu ellisabeth borne sortez
des slogans des postures en voulant
faire croire en voulant faire l'amalgame
entre notre texte et les positions de
l'extrême droite les mots les mots ont
un sens monsieur les mot ont un sens
monsieur le Président chassigne
l'extrême droite c'est le rejet des
étrangers par principe parce qu'ils sont
étrangers l'extrême droite c'est la
préférence nationale nous nous yons à
l'intégration par le travail nous nous
voulons nous nous voulons continuer à
former des talents et à diffuser notre
culture en accueillant des étudiants
internationaux l'extrême
[Musique]
droite l'extrême droite l'extrême droite
c'est le refus d'accueillir même ceux
qui sont en danger le droit d'asile
c'est au cœur de nos valeurs monsieur le
Président chass son voà elle répondait
au président du groupe communiste à
l'Assemblée André chassigne euh Pascal
Pino euh est-ce voilà est-ce qu'elle a
finalement raison de faire la différence
de dire cette loi telle qu'elle ressort
de la commission mixte paritaire c'est
une loi effectivement LR mais pas RN non
c'est pas une loi RN par exemple on
parle de la préférence nationale la
préférence nationale c'est
d'exclure d'exclure selon le critère de
la nationalité euh les étrangers de
l'accès à telle ou telle aide là ça
n'est pas le cas dans la loi on durcit
les conditions d'accès en terme de durée
sur le territoire national et cetera on
les durcit on n'est pas dans de la
préférence nationale à l'état pur hein
ce qui a toujours été le projet du Front
national puis du rassemblement national
donc ça n'est pas le projet du RN mais
le RN avait dit d'ailleurs auparavant si
ça va dans le bon sens nous
accompagnerons le sens et en plus de ça
on s'imera le trou regardez ce qui ça y
est on est en plein d dans et comme
toujours à chaque fois qu'il y a cette
question du RN les grands mots sortent
les postures le camp du Bien et le camp
du mal et cetera et on ne parle plus
tellement du sujet pardon c'est daté ah
oui oui oui oui oui oui bien sûr parce
que tout de même depuis juin 2022 il y a
une vraie majorité relative mais qui est
au fond presque une grosse minorité hein
euh et il faut bien euh aller chercher
les voies donc construire sans cesse des
compromis sur le social plutôt avec la
gauche sur leur régalien on le voit
plutôt avec la droite alrael temp
jusqu'au rassemblement national bien sûr
bien sûr c'est c'est c'est intéressant
parce que on est dans la normalisation
souhaitée par le bienûr mais bien sûr
euh surtout qu'aujourd'hui n'oublions
pas que la première force politique en
France c'est le rassemblement national
il suffit de regarder les enquêtes tous
les jours oui on regardera d'ailleurs
tout tout à l'heure l'enquête que doxa
et mascaré ont fait pour pour Public
Sénat et la presse quotidienne régionale
sur des des projections de de vote si on
votait dimanche aux européenne on on
vous donnera ça tout à
l'heure quand vous entendez Pascal
Perino finalement nous donner ses
arguments ça vous fait ça vous fait
tiquer mais bon voilà il y a une
normalisation on peut la regretter on
doit l'accepter comment vous le réagiss
à ça je crois que c'est plus qu'une
normalisation là qu'on est en train de
de de faire pour le rassemblement
national c'est vraiment une de lancement
terrible est-ce que mais attendez on po
toujours notre responsabilité mais il y
il y a il y a des Français qui votent et
il y a des
enquêtesion a il y a le compromis de
l'Assemblée et du Sénat avec cette CMP
si on revient au discours d'Emmanuel
Macron en 2022 quand il a gagné il a dit
j'ai bien compris que on m'a élu aussi
pour éviter Marine Le Pen et que ce vote
m'oblige mais il oblige en quoi en rien
du tout c'est-à-dire que là on se dit
bah finalement j'aurais mieux fait de
voter rassemblement national parce que
justement c'est le parti qui peut aller
encore plus loin sur cette fermeté parce
que on va pas s'arrêter à 3 mois pour
les allocations de logement par exemple
on va aller jusqu'à 5 an où on va aller
jusqu'à bah si c'est des étrangers ils
auront pas du tout de logement en fait
il y a une espèce de ramp de lancement
qui est terriblement faite là avec cette
façon de de se mettre à genou par
rapport à des mesures c'est un début
c'est un début c'est un début c'est un
changement pardon vous interromp
l'argument que vous nous donnez Émilie
c'est exactement celui d'Olivier fort le
le premier iste qui parle de trahison on
l'écoute c'est une trahison une trahison
pour toutes celles et ceux qui ont fait
le choix précisément de de faire barrage
à l'extrême droite en votant Emmanuel
Macron et c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est très dangereux aussi parce que
quel est celui ou celle qui acceptera
encore de faire barrage demain si
l'entalité se présentait avec un
macroniste plus personne ne peut y
croire plus personne ne peut accepter
l'idée que on fait barrage à l'extrême
droite avec le vote vote Renaissance ou
le vote Macron ça n'est plus possible
parce qu'ils appliquent eux-mêmes la
politique de Marien Le Pen et je la vois
se féliciter se délecté de ce moment où
au fond les combats de son père sont en
train d'être en fait à la fois mis en
valeur et achevé par Emmanuel Macron
lui-même lui qui avait été élu
précisément pour faire barrage à ces
idéesl c'est un
scandale est-ce qu'on peut analyser ça
comme ça c'est Emmanuel Macron qui vient
de trahir les électeurs de gauche qui
avaient voté pour lui en en 2022 alors
peut-être ceux qui avent voté surtout
pour lui en en 2017 je pense que
justement dans dans le vote de ce soir
ce sera intéressant de de regarder parmi
les députés qui est le le vote des
députés selon que ce sont des députés
qui viennent de la législature 2017 ou
2022 où sa base électorale était déjà un
peu plus à droite pour Emmanuel Macron
le fait qu'il fasse des majorités de
compromis c'est relativement attendu par
les Français ils sont d'ailleurs même
très en attendre du fait que l'ensemble
des sensibilités de l'Assemblée
nationale soit soit prise en compte en
revanche si c'était systématiquement des
majorités penchant à droite là ce ne
serait plus le président du en même
temps qui pour la première fois on a été
victime parce que c'est vrai que le en
même temps s'est retourné contre lui
avec les les majorités et de gauche et
de droite qui qui votent la motion de de
rejet pour l'instant ça n'apparaîtrait
pas forcément une traittrise surtout si
la majorité est atteinte sans le vote
des députés rassemblement national mais
ça peut être une brique fondatrice du
sentiment d'ingouvernabilité
d'incapacité à construire des majorités
deux présidents penchant définitivement
à droite ça peut être les les prémisses
d'une de quelque chose qui va fragmenter
mais une petite question arithmétique
pour bien alors je vais vous interrompre
pardon vous la poserez juste après
puisque Quentin calm surveillis ça sur
nos écrans de contrôle est avec Bruno
retaillot le président du groupe LR ici
au Sénat Quentin c'est à vous oui
effectivement Thomas merci Bruno rotot
de venir au micro de Public Sénat pour
cette première réaction depuis l'accord
rrouvé en commission mixte paritaire
qu'est-ce que vous dites sur ce qui
ressort de cette réunion de la CMP c'est
un texte qui vous convient car proche de
celui du Sénat ça ne vous pouvez pas
être autrement je veux pas avoir le
triomphe modeste mais très franchement
il y avait un seul texte le seul texte
qui avait été voté par une des deux
assemblées du Parlement français c'est
le texte du Sénat donc ça ne pouvait
être que un texte tout proche et on a eu
de belles victoires mais la victoire
c'est je pense pour les Français près de
80 % des Français nous demandent de la
fermeté 80 % pensent qu'il y a trop
d'immigration en France et par rapport
au passé ce qui est intéressant à noter
c'est que ce sont des Français de droite
mais a de gauche donc c'est un très
large consensus alors que vous savez que
nous sommes un peuple un peu gaulois
curelleur et que nous sommes souvent
très fracturé et bien sur cette question
migratoire les Français ont cette
conscience que désormais il faut mettre
fin au désordre migratoire une réaction
au fait que Marine Le Pen appelle à
voter le texte qui ressort de la CMP on
peut se réjouir d'une victoire
idéologique dit la présidente du groupe
RN à l'Assemblée nationale elle vous
tire un peu la victoire elle aussi non
elle veut voler la victoire mais la
vérité elle est très très simple c'est
que d'ailleurs dès la lecture au Sénat
les représentants les représentants du
rassemblement national se sont opposés
voilà et ce que je veux dire c'est que
nous portons ici au Sénat depuis des
années et des années un certain nombre
de convictions qu'on a exprimé dans des
rapports avec François Noë buffet nous
les avons exprimé par exemple sur la
manifestation de la volonté c'était un
dispositif pas quoi que monsieur
bardellaa était même pas en culotte
courte donc arrêtons le scandale elle se
réj du fait que la priorité nationale
rentre dans la loi et que ça c'est une
victoire idéologique pour le RN non la
priorité nationale au sens de Madame Le
Pen c'était de réserver par exemple les
allocation familiale exclusivement au
français nous on a un temps de carence
tout simplement parce qu'on considère
que lorsqu'on entre sur le territoire
national dans la communauté nationale et
bien il y a un équilibre entre des
devoirs et de droits les Français en ont
marre de payer de plus en plus souvent
pour des services publics qui sont de
moins en moins performants et je pense
qu'il faut avoir une différence
c'est naturel c'est la différence qui
est une différence fondamentale entre
des citoyens nationaux et des gens qui
viennent de l'extérieur j'ai une
dernière question sur le fond du texte
vous ne vouliez pas de régularisation
dans ce projet de loi il y aura bien un
article 4 bis avec des régularisations
au cas par cas vous avez dû concéder
cela vous le reconnaissez vous voulez
rire non mais vous voulez rire toujours
pas compris ceétait l'article 4 b non il
y avait un article
3 c'était un droit opposable on a
supprimé l'article 3 à partir du il y
avait plus d'article 3 il y avait la
circulaire Vals et bien nous on a
renforcé la circulaire Vals on l'a
renforcé dans son champ d'application
c'est seulement les métiers au tenstion
on l'a renforcé dans son contrôle
désormais avec le mode de vie avec
l'ordre public avec les principes de la
République
jyz voyez toutes les différences par
rapport à la circulaire Vals bien c'est
du beau travail ça non et merci pour
cette réaction en direct au micro de
public brun merci à vous merci à tous
les deux merci Quentin et n'hésitez pas
évidemment à nous faire signe avec
d'autres invités ou avec d'autres
informations Pascal
Perino on peut dire ce soir que c'est
une revanche deslr on peut aller jusque
là oui d'une certaine manière parce
qu'ils avaient bien du mal à exister
plus à l'Assemblée nationale d'ailleurs
qu'au Sénat parce que ce qui est
important c'est vrai dans ce que dit le
président du groupe parlementaire au
Sénat
DLR le projet qui a été voté au c'est un
projet qui a été voté dans une assemblée
dans lequel il y a pour ainsi dire
absolument pas le rassemble ement
national à savoir le Sénat c'est c'est
un projet L S donc il faut voyez un peu
modérer cette impression qui consiste à
dire c'est une victoire du rassemblement
national et cetera au fond il continue
un combat qu'il mène d'ailleurs depuis
plusieurs années hein alors ensuite on
peut dire il y a une influence
idéologique beaucoup plus large la
fameuse leupénisation des esprits mais
ça j'allais dire ça datein ça date et ça
touche pas simplement des députés ou des
sénateurs ça touche les Français
simplement hein euh donc oui les LR
arrivent là à se refaire une santé
d'abord ils sont unis entre le Cénat et
l'Assemblée nationale ça c'est c'est
très important parce qu'on avait de plus
en plus de LR peut-être trois d'ailleurs
il y avait le parti il y avait celui du
Sénat puis il y avait celui de
l'Assemblée nationale ça faisant il leur
faudra trouver un candidat pour 2020 ça
oui mais ça bon ils ont le temps hein
ils ont le temps ils ont trouvé déjà un
candidat apparemment pour pour les
européennes h chaqueose par que pour
l'instant personne n'a à peu près de
candidat pour la prochaine prés
rapidement sur les il y a encore
beaucoup sur lesr je pense que la
séquence elle elle sera pas très durable
elle va être courte cette séquence parce
que oui il se cramponne sur ce sujet de
l'immigration il cour derrière les idées
du rassemblement national parce que
c'est leur identité et que globalement
ils n'ont pas développé depuis le temps
beaucoup d'autres idées qui les
différencierit forcément des macronistes
donc si on tire un petit peu plus sur la
droite et du du rassemblement national
ils sont sur l'immigration sauf qu'ils
ont pas compris que le rassemblement
national il a ouvert les vannes sur les
thématiques et on l'a bien vu avec une
Marine Le Pen qui en 2022 a parlé
surtout du pouvoir d'achat donc quelque
part le rassemblement national sera
toujours plus fort sur ses fondamentaux
et il a même plus besoin d'en rajouter
10000 couches donc je pense que cette
cette victoire évidemment c'est normal
qu'il s'en félicite et qu' qu'ils en
fassent beaucoup mais ça sera pas
durable
peut-être y a quand même un message
d'efficacité lancé par le parti LR à ses
électeurs ce soir de savoirfaire
politique tout à fait absolument le
texte c'est le nôtre et c'est celui
alors on va voir s'il passe ou pas dans
quelqu S mais c'est celui qui mais la
démonstration voilà d'un certain
savoir-faire politique mais je je
rebonis ce qui a été sur ce qui a été
dit qui est intéressant c'est que sur
les préoccupations des électeurs les
deux principales préoccupations des
électeurs LR c'est la sécurité et
l'immigration mais les deux principales
préoccupations des sympathisants RN
c'est l'immigration et le pouvoir
d'achat h finalement couple sécurité
immigration est quand même près des
prérogatives LR enfin en tout cas des
grosses préoccupation de le leurs
électeurs donc ça va bien dans leur sens
et c'est vrai que cet accord avec une
passerelle intelligente entre le Sénat
et l'Assemblée nationale c'est la
démonstration d'un savoir faire
politique laticia on arrive à quoi 40
jours je crois de tractation
parlementaire autour de ce texte ce qui
va rester selon vous c'est le un
spectacle politique déplorable dont la
démocratie est la grande perdante
expliquez-nous pourquoi vous dites ça
écoutez je
je sais qu'ici on on aime l'analyse et
que on la met vraiment voilà au début de
toutes les discussions je crains que les
Français ne retiennent pas les points
sur lesquels la commission mixte
paritaire s'est déchiré par exemple les
grands points de cette loi immigration
je pense que ce qui va rester c'est ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure Bruno
retaillot sous les flash voilà en fait
il faut se regarder où sont les
projecteurs aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui
intéresse les Français qui est sur la
scène qui est est sur le devant de la
scène ensuite les idées viendront bien
sûr les idées arrivent toujours mais
pour le moment effectivement je crois
que le spectacle déplorable que donnent
les politiques grâce aux
médias va détruire les bases de notre
démocratie représentative euh le
problème c'est que tout le monde se se
jette la balle de la responsabilité bah
oui hein depuis euh on commence à en
avoir l'habitude les Français aussi hein
depuis euh le feuilleton hein des
retraites au printemps dernier là
maintenant c'est la tragédie de la loi
immigration où les les oppositions elle
est fit en tête disent par exemple là
pour
l'immigration vous savez on on entend à
nouveau la petite musique du dénis de
démocratie alors les uns accusent les
autres le la l'opposition accuse la
majorité d'un dénis de démocratie de
cettet fait complètement à la main de LR
ce petit parti qui finalement comme je
disais tout à l'heure n'a pas beaucoup
de justification et alors de son côté la
majorité accuse les minorités qui ont
empêché le débat parlementaire tout
simplement comme l'a fait François
Baayou qui est proche he d'Emmanuel
Macron sur RTL dimanche il a dit que les
députés qui avaient refusé le débat
finalement ne n'auraient pas la mission
que les Français leur avaient donné en
refusant de travailler c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont été élus et ils refusent leur
mission il refuse de débattre et il
refuse de voter les lois François
baayrou qui selon nos confrères de de
l'Agence France Presse alors c'est
plusieurs des sources concordantes comme
on dit qui qui le cite François
n'accepte pas un texte revendiqué par le
rassemblement national voilà le
président du MoDem on verra bien comment
vote les députés modem tout à l'heure et
la presse dans tout ça laéticia et bien
les médias on on en est l'illustration
ce soir profite de ce chaos
ubuesque pour comme on dit dans le
jargon feuilletonner vous savez on crée
un feuilleton donc on attend tous le
prochain épisode qu'est-ce qui va se
passer et alors on a même pas besoin
d'allumer la télé on a tous sur no
téléphone tone portable ça tombe comme
ça minute après minute un tel accuse un
tel qui accuse un tel et alors je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez vu le journal
l'opinion a résumé la problématique dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui à sa
Une aujourd'hui il dit la démocratie à H
clos pourquoi parce que les journalistes
vont encore plus loin ils disent que
finalement la loi immigration ne va pas
sortir de la CMP mais des dîners à hlos
qui se sont organisés autour desabet
born comme celui d'hier soir par exemple
où elle avait deux ministres gérérald
d'manin Franck rester et quatre
représentants DLR à Matignon elle les a
multiplié hein c'est dîner Elisabeth Bor
il y a un autre exemple c'est le coup de
téléphone du président de la République
coup de téléphone à Elisabeth borne et à
Bruno Rayo qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
alors qu'il recevait les handballeuses
françaises victorieux victorieus he
championne du monde et alors ça ça a
fait aussi sur nos téléphones on a tous
reçu le pouche de notification alors on
sait qui a appelé qui qui a reçu qui a
dîner normalement ces informations là
sont censé rester privés ah oui mais
c'est le rôle des journalistes de les
faire sortir aussi d'ailleurs Bruno
rillou a démenti ce ce coup de fil
présidentiel ex et l'Élisée également et
alors les journalist ont ce rôle là mais
aussi les politiques c'est-à-dire que
les politiques font fuiter ces
informations et les médias les
reprennent et donc vous nous dites quoi
que ça réduit la démocratie à ses à ses
coups de téléphone oui au final on a
l'impression que la loi immigration s
joué à Hu clos c'est vrai dans le hulos
du pouvoir et et c'est vrai que on a
l'impression d'être d'avoir regardé ce
ce feuilleton de la loi immigration dans
nos dans nos canapés paisiblement mais
comme on regarderait Dallas ou amour
gloire et beauté amour Glo et beuté be
j'ésite entre les deux mais ceux qui ont
la référence chis sur des v des
références qui commencent à dater un
petit peu on n'est pas tous forcément
d'accord mais mais je trouve que c'est
intéressant pour lancer cette partie du
du débat autour de de de ce thème
d'affaiblissement de la démocratie on
peut aussi considérer je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez Pascal Perin tiens
peut-être que bon ben on a une CMP qui a
fonctionné des des des des sénateurs des
députés qui ont discuté même si
effectivement bon on a eu un peu
l'impression que le centre de gravité se
décaler vers vers vers matigon alors je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
François
patria le le président du groupe
Renaissance je simplifie ici au Sénat
est avec Quentin calm
Quentin accord trouvé entre députés et
sénateurs en commission mixte paritaire
c'est un bon accord qui a été trouvé
écoutez je pense que cet accord nous
l'avons travaillé avec le gouvernement
avec Madame borne à plusieurs reprises à
matigon le gouvernement avait fixé ses
propres lignes rouges qui concernit sur
trois points à l'origine en fin de
compte les choses ont évolué sur H
points et non des moindes sur le code de
la nationalité sur l'ame sur la
rédaction de l'article 4 bis sur le
logement d'urgence sur les étudiants sur
les les allocations familiales le reste
les choses ont évolué dans le sens où
nous le souhaitions à partir du moment
où nous sommes majoritaires et qu'on
parle du texte du Sénat bien entendu
c'est pas seulement un compromis c'est
un accord qui a été je crois accepté y
compris par le président de la
commission mix paritaire ce matin ah
donc dites ça je je vous interromps mais
Sacha alier vient d'annoncer que à titre
personnel il allit voter contre l'accord
trouvé en CMP tout comme Monsieur mati
le chef de fil des députés modem les
multiplications hein comme ça de
réaction de députés qui à titre
personnel annonce qu'ils ne vont pas
voter ou voter contre l'accord de la CMP
que ça vous évoque je crois d'abord
qu'il faut reprendre un peu de calme et
un peu de de hauteur en l'occurrence on
verra bien ce qui se passera ce soir
j'ai compris que les chefs de la
majorité de l'Assemblée nationale sont à
l'heure actuelle àéisé ce que je veux
dire aujourd'hui c'est que le président
de la commission des lois la commission
mix paritaire a voté l'accord il a
accepté l'accord en commission il a
accepté l'accord mission et pourquoi
veut-il changer d'avis
maintenant parce que parce que le groupe
LR aujourd'hui change son vote mais je
crois qu'il faut évacuer la position des
LR elle ne nous concerne pas elle ne
nous n inéresse pas le LR qui voulait
voter contre hier veut voter pour
aujourd'hui c'est un vote tactique
politique que nous devons ignorer
aujourd'hui nous devons nous concentrer
sur l'accord qui a été élaboré avec les
républicains et le gouvernement
aujourd'hui donc le vote des des RN vous
voulez dire ou le vote deslr le vote des
Le Vot des RN pardon Le Vot RN ne n
concerne pas voilà ok donc ça ça ne vous
dérange pas que à la fin le texte
convienne au rassemblement national pas
quelque chose ça c'est un vote tactique
nous ne votons pas aujourd'hui avec le
RN le RN fait ce qu'il veut à côté
chaque fois que le Ren changer de vote
nous devions changer notre vote
nous-même pas du tout on doit pas tenir
compte aujourd'hui du vote RN pour nous
déterminer on doit tenir compte de
l'accord qui a été construit patiemment
avec le gouvernement et la majorité et
la majorité du Sénat cet accord la CMP
l'a validé les réactions maintenant en
fonction du vote du RN je crois
aujourd'hui doivent être prises avec
beaucoup de de hauteur sans détourner
aujourd'hui et voter le texte qui a été
const monsieur patri dernière question
vous reconnaissez quand même une crise
au sein de la majorité pour qu'on en
vienne à une réunion à l'Élysée avec les
ministres concer con C les cadres de
renaissance et les autres partis de la
majorité c'est bien qu'il y a une crise
j'ai bien le sentiment qu'il y a une
partie de la majorité qui aujourd'hui se
sent mal à l'aise avec elle aurait voulu
le texte de l'Assemblée mais quand on
n'est pas majoritaire est-ce qu'on peut
avoir le texte de l'Assemblée soit il
voulait qu'il y ait pas de texte soit on
veut quand même que le gouvernement que
la France dispose des outils pour
pouvoir aujourd'hui mieux régler les
problèmes d'expulsion ou d'évacuation
des gens qui n'ont rien à faaytique
Monsieur c'est pas la réelle politique
c'est c'est la politique tout simplement
qui répond aux attentes des Français
merci merci pour cette réaction en
direct le public c'est mon merci merci à
tous les deux merci Quentin encore une
fois Pascal Perino c'est c'est
intéressant ce que nous dit François
patria il est en train de nous dire là
ça se joue à l'Élysée et et attendons
attendons le vote quoi c'estàdire que
peut-être que Emmanuel Macron va
remettre de la cohérence dans dans le
vote des députés hésitants et oui le
parti de la majorité parlementaire du
moins à l'Assemblée nationale c'est le
parti du président et comme toujours
sous la 5e République quand il y a
conflit c'est le président ident de la
République qui tente de remettre de
l'ordre on verra sil est capable de
remettre de l'ordre ou si voilà il y a
quelques forces qui résiste à l'appel à
la discipline du du président de la
République et ce sera quand même
éclairant pour la suite du quinena c'est
ça que c'est aussi passionnant de de
voir ce qui se déroule ce soir c'est ça
qui est important parce que s'il y avait
j'allais dire beaucoup de pertes en
ligne c'est le scénario un peu du Parti
socialiste à la fin de la présidence
Hollande c'est-à-dire ça se
délite voilà si en revanche voilà les
fronddeurs ce sont quelques unités
qu'est-ce que ça changera façon il se
représent pas donc non non non non non
si capit
àé avant avant la la présidentielle à
laquelle ne se représentera pas il y a
tout même 3 ans à tenir donc c'est
important pour pour l'avenir surtout
quand il dit voilà moi pour l'instant je
refuse la dissolution et cetera donc il
faut qu'il donne du contenu avec une
majorité qui tienne euh et qui ne voilà
ne ne se dissolve pas sous l'impact des
frondeurs on aura la réponse très
bientôt oui c'est pour ça que cette
soirée elle va être passionnante puisque
je vous rappelle là on est dans un quart
d'heure le vote commence au Sénat et à
21h30 à l'Assemblée Émilie zapalski
c'est je voudrais qu'on se projette
justement sur cette capacité d'Emmanuel
Macron à continuer de de réformer et à
trouver une majorité je ne sais pas ce
qui va se passer ce soir mais s'il perd
plusieurs dizaines de de députés sur ce
vote de la loi immigration c'est une
hypothèse pourra-t-il les récupérer sur
d'autres textes voyez c'est ce qui est
en train de se jouer moi j'y crois pas
beaucoup alors je sais pas comment il va
rétablir la cohérence hein si c'est le
bâton cohésion mais euh je pense que les
têtes vont voilà vont redescendre mais
c'est la première fois j'ai l'impression
qu'ils sont assez qu'ils sont allés
aussi loin Sacha aoulier on a entendu
aussi des ministres mettre dans la
balance leur démission euh on a vu hein
dans dans un article du Figaro qu' avait
eu des des des des rumeurs comme quoi
trois ministres notamment euh vous
voulait démissionner si le texte allait
jusque là s ferme euh c'est la première
fois François bairou hein je rappelle
l'une des infos de cette fin
d'après-midi je je vais retrouver la
citation je sais plus où il est
n'acceptera pas un texte revendiqué par
le rassemblement on sait pas ce que ça
veut dire mais en tout cas en tout cas
c'est une
voilà de vote d'abstention à minima quoi
minima mais je pense que c'est c'est un
signe c'est un signe parce que c'est la
première fois en effet qu' sortent du
bois autant que ce soit prier ou deuxème
qu'inquena en marquant ça moi a priori
et puis vu les efforts qu'ils ont fait à
mon avis Emmanuel Macron va les ramener
à la raison ce soir probablement mais
c'est un signal après c'est le sens à
donner de ce quinquena qui n'a pas de
sens depuis le début ce deuxème mandat
euh réforme des retraites alors si il a
un sens c'est de plus en plus à droite
finalement réforme des retraites à 64
ans là l'immigration on voit que les
plus fortes réformes elles sont quand
même marquées à droite mais ce qu'on
voit surtout et c'est vrai que c'est la
majorité relatif qui l'oblige c'est que
le sens du quinena c'est surtout faire
des compromis mais est-ce que tout
toutes les fins du compromis justifier
les moyens c'est ça qu'il va
falloir mais c'est c'est le sens
maintenant qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
va impliquer est-ce qu'il va faire un
petit coup à gauche avec je sais pas une
réforme
sur on on va voir on va voir ce qui
passe je je rappelle pardon LTI allezy
il y a quand même eu l'inscription dans
la Constitution de l'intervution
volontaire de grossesse et la fin dit
qui doit arriver fin fév il y avait pas
pri dans la demeure sur l'vg non plus
hein alors on on a entendu un
représentant de
taillot on a entendu un
représentant de renaissance Marie-Pierre
de la Gonterie qui a participé
d'ailleurs à cette commission paritaire
sénatrice socialiste de Paris est avec
Quentin calm exactement Thomas elle est
bien membre elle était membre de cette
commission x paritaire réunie depuis
hier bonsoir madame de La Gonterie on
apprend cette réunion de crise on peut
le dire entre le Président de la
République et plusieurs cadres de sa
majorité avec les ministres concernés
qu'est-ce ça vous évoque cette réunion
là qui vient de s'improviser à l'Élysée
B je pense qu'il une comment dire il y a
un décrochage total entre la tête de
l'État et la base si on peut dire
notamment les députés c'està-dire que ce
qui s'est passé en commission mixte
paritaire n'a pas été une surprise le
texte nous ne nous convenait pas nous
l'avons combattu du Sénat donc comment
se fait-il qu'il n'y ait pas eu
anticipation
euh bon donc effectivement le il semble
que le vote soit extrêmement peu assuré
ce qui est pas très étonnant parce que
ce texte ça a été dit d'ailleurs en
commission mixte paritaire à la fin de
la commission mixte paritaire les
représentants du rassemblement national
ont félicité mais j'utilise les mots ont
félicité la droite et les macronistes
d'avoir d'être venu sur leur thèse on
entend ça chaoulier qui annonce ce soir
qu'il va voter contre le texte sorti de
la CMP il l'a voté on est d'accord à la
fin de la CMP tel que vous y avez
assisté est-ce que vous l'avez entendu
pendant ces de jours dire que ce texte
n'allait pas lui lui convenir à la fin
non mais bon il présidait la CMP donc il
n'avait avait pas à s'exprimer
particulièrement il y avait les membres
de son groupe il votait quand même oui
mais alors je vous cache pas que j'ai
pas passé mon temps à surveiller son
vote j'ai plutôt regardé le vote du
rassemblement national à la ça vous
évoque ces ces figures de renaissance
qui annonce ce soir notamment monsieur
mati pour le modem qu'il vont voter
contre mais encore une fois euh on pense
trop que quand on fait de la politique
on est totalement déshumanisé qu'on a
jamais de conviction que tout est
possible on sait bien depuis un certain
temps que ce texte dérive on sait bien
qu'il y a un problème avec la thèse du
rassemblement national la préférence
nationale on on a écoutez j'ai dénoncé
ici dans cette hémicycle lors de
l'explication de vote sur le texte le
fait que les digues étaient rompu entre
la droite française et le Front national
donc tout ça n'est pas nouveau mais je
pense que tout ça a été sous-estimé et
que au fond ces ces députés n' n'ont pas
été suffisamment respectés mais pour
Emmanuel Macron et c'est ma dernière
question est-ce que c'est un tournant ce
qui se joue autour de ce texte en terme
de ligne politique selon vous parce que
vous parliez de cette rupture de de
barrage entre LR et le RN là ça va plus
loin aujourd'hui oui c'est-à-dire que on
a assisté à la fin du macronisme
c'est-à-dire que Emmanuel Macron voulait
un texte coûte que coûte y compris en
étant sous la dictée de de de des
républicains y compris en allant
éventuellement sur les terres de
l'extrême droite donc il y a une il y a
une fracture sur la conception politique
que défendait Emmanuel Macron ensuite
oui je pense que ça va être un tournant
très rude chez les Français parce que
beaucoup vous savez on comment dire on
cru c'est pas péjoratif dans la bouche
on cru que Macron allait proposer autre
chose et puis allait il l'avait dit
faire barrage
entre contre contre le Front National et
là il s'allie avec eux bien merci merci
Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie sénatrice
socialiste de Paris vous étiez membrre
de cette CMP merci pour cette réaction à
notre micro merci à tous les deux jour
et qu'on qu'on s'intéresse et qu'on
rentre un peu dans le détail de ce
baromètre odoxa mascaré pour Public
Sénat et et la presse quotidienne
régionale avec d'abord un un premier
élément qui concerne Emmanuel Macron euh
c'était avant même évidemment les les
événements de ces dernières 48 heures on
voyait déjà ça sa code de popularité
baissée à la question el Macron est-il
un bon Président de la République non 66
% oui 33 % une baisse de 2 points c'est
son socle de gauche qui se fragilisait
déjà un petit peu et qui continue de se
fragiliser est-ce que c'est ça l'analyse
ou pas d'ailleurs non non pas
particulièrement parce qu'il a baissé un
peu chez chez LR aussi mais ça reste
tendantiel mais ce qu'il faut noter pour
emmanuelord Macron si on fait le le
bilan de son année 2023 c'est qu'il
avait déjà perdu des points fortement
avec la réforme des retraites sa côte de
popularité était légèrement remonté il y
avait son attitude qui avait été saluée
face au conflit israëlo-palestinien là
il reperre de points et au global sur
l'année 2023 il aura perdu 8 points il y
a un mois ce qu'on observait c'était un
fort risque de vote sanction aux
élections européennes c'est la première
fois que les Français retourneront aux
urnes après la séquence de la
présidentielle et des législatives là on
va même au-delà du vote sanction aux
élections européennes il y a un
sentiment d'ingouvernabilité qui a
commencé à se diffuser pas dit qu'il va
se qu' va se solidifier mais il y a ce
sentiment là et il y a le côté
réformiste d'Emmanuel Macron qui peut
peut-être être un peu affecté ce
réformisme un peu dynamique face au vent
contraire le décloisonnement
l'efficacité de la politique là c'est
peut-être que son image peut être sapée
sur ce côté-là et surtout auprès de son
socle électoral on l'a en signale faible
mais chez ellisabeth borne elle perd 10
points chez les sympathisants
Renaissance ce mois-ci un mot rapide
Pascal Perino sur le rendez-vous que
Emmanuel Macron donne à rendez-vous avec
la nation en janvier sortir du chapeau
le président de la répu on verra il y a
nécessité voyez on est on est depuis des
semaines j'allais dire des mois on passe
d'un événement à un événement avec des
jeux parlementaires complexes et cetera
il faut redonner un peu de j'allais dire
d'espace d'accord alors l'espace vous
nous le donnerez un peu plus tard parce
que j'en donne
à le sénateur écologiste pardon Pascal
qui est avec Quentin oui effectivement
Thomas je suis avec bonjour Monsieur J
une réaction à ce se joue en ce moment
le sans surprise le Sénat qui dans
quelques minutes va adopter les
conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire ce sera plus compliqué à
l'Assemblée nationale et il y a une
réunion de crise all liser en ce moment
avec les casades de la majorité les
ministres concernés qu'est-ce ça vous
évoque cette situation en ce moment une
faillite politique et morale pour le
président de la République il a voulu
faire de la tactique en mettant de côté
les valeurs de la République les valeurs
du camp qu'il est censé représenter les
valeurs de celles et ceux qui ont voté
pour lui deux fois en 2017 en 2022 pour
éviter Le Pen vous savez j'ai comparé
cette situation au brexit qu'avait lancé
David Cameron à ce point-là oui parce
qu'il voulait faire de la tactique en
pensant qu'il jouer à coup sûr mais à
partir du moment où vous créez un débat
qui est fondé sur des mensonges des
contrevérités des fantasmes sur
l'immigration que la société est aussi
déstabilisée angoissée et ben vous
ouvrez la boîte du pire vous ouvrez la
boîte de la libération de la parole et
des actes racistes vous ouvrez la boîte
de la remise en cause des valeurs de la
République et on voit aujourd'hui qu'il
ne tient plus sa majorité et on comprend
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire
selon vous retirer le texte depuis le
début retirer le texte on peut
parfaitement par en améliorant la
circulaire Vals mieux régulariser les
personnes qui travaillent et qui
participe de notre pays tout le monde
convient qu'il faut pas remettre en
cause laame on va pas remettre en cause
le droit du sol c'est ça que contient ce
texte vous rendez compte la victoire
culturelle politique et à ce
électoral de Marine Le Pen dans lequel
le président de la République nous
engageer bien merci merci en jado pour
cette réaction en direct au micro de
Public Sénat merci Quentin on approche
de l'heure qui était prévue mais je je
vois les images de la séance il y a
encore discussion autour d'un autre
texte il y aura sans doute une
suspension de séance avant que le vote
n'intervienne sur cette loi immigration
donc on a encore le temps d'analyser les
uns et les autres et Pascal je vous
redonne la parole sur la marge de
manœuvre d'un Emmanuel Macron qui a déjà
essayé d'inventer beaucoup de voilà dire
d'initiative pour redonner du souffle à
à son
quinquena on le voit mal annoncer la
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
parce qu'il en ressortirait sans doute
pas une majorité plus plus solide et
encore personne sauf le RN un intérêt à
une dissolution donc qu'est-ce donc en
effet il faut voilà parce que il y a il
y a 3 ans qui un peu plus de 3 ans même
qui qui attendent le président et il va
falloir redonner un peu de souffle alors
qu'il n'arrive pas à trouver ce second
souffle depuis 2000 22 alors on peut
imag on pourrait imaginer hein on
pourrait imaginer un grand débat Pascal
Perino c'est un spécialist grandb grand
grandbage je ne crois pas je après le
grand cirque un grand déballage une
explication au yeux dans les yeux avec
les Français un macoup des politiques
les Français ils attendent à ce que les
hommes politiques et au premier rang
desquels le président fasse des choses
bon là on peut en discuter voilà il y a
cette loi immigration qui a été votée il
y a quelques mois c'était la loi sur les
retraites et cetera spp ça déplaît mais
il y a des actes et certains Français
peuvent avoir l'impression on verra que
les choses changent mais là c'est
intéressant ça malgré la difficulté il y
a des réfes qui passent sûr ça peut être
mis à son crédit ça et ça ça peut être
mis à son crédit alors que en face on a
très souvent le ministère de la parole
et le ministère des indignations hein là
il y a des choses qui sont faites alors
on peut imaginer que dans les mois qui
viennent dans la perspective du
macronisme original il s'occupe un peu
j'allis dire de sa gauche alors il y a
des dossiers fait comme le travail par
exemple sur lequel il pourrait trouver
euh à construire des majorités puisque
c'est le défi qui est le sien le défi de
son camp avec plutôt des forces de
gauche même si on le voit ce soir il a
fortement irrité les forces de gauche
mais les forces de gauche c'est normal
sindigne ce soir de de de de ce qui se
passe mais enfin il y a une semaine il
votaient aussi avec le rassemblement
national la motion de rejet et je me
souviens des images qui étaient
extrêmement frappantes où il y avait
toute la gauche nupese qui applaudissait
avec qui avec le rassemblement national
cette victoire du rejet de de de
discuter le texte donc vous voyez il y a
beaucoup de postures il faut bien REC
cononnaître il y a beaucoup de postures
et puis si vous me permettez simplement
20 secondes il y a tout le monde sent
que le Front National est à la hausse
dans la perspective bien avant ce ce ce
projet de loi immigration d'as il est à
la hausse et maintenant on voit très
bien que commence à savoir mais qui a
fait monter hein qui a fait monter le
Front national al la gauche va dire
c'est Macron Macron va dire c'est la
gauche ou d'autres choses LR va dire bah
voilà ce sont les ambiguïtés de Macron
et c'est la démagogie de la gauche voyez
ça y est ça a commencé ça a commencé de
pour préparer la soirée la soirée de des
européennes de joint
où chance de commenter la victoire du
rassemblement national on commentera
votre sondage un mot de la réaction à à
l'éisée la réaction du président de la
République ltia cet après-midi il se
disait à l'Élysée que Emmanuel Macron
était agacé et voulait tourner la page
et voulait en finir rapidement donc on
imagine la teneur deion ce soir on va
voir mais alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que elle est en train de se mettre
en place toute la rhtorique les éléments
de langage on appelle ça en
communication politique du président qui
arrive à la fin de son mandat puisque
tout le monde dit tout son endroit je
dit Emmanuel Macron craint plus que tout
de laisser le pouvoir à l'extrême droite
or quand on vous écoute ce soir on a
compris que c'est c'était le scénario en
tout cas qui tenait laorde aujourd'hui
donc en gros il commence à préparer son
terrain pour sa postérité pour expliquer
que ce n'est pas de sa faute ouais avant
avant 2027 il y a effectivement les
européennes le mois de
juinestrand donc vous avez interrogé les
Français sur leurs intention de vote la
question c'était si les élections
européennes avaient lieu dimanche
prochain pour laquelle des listes
suivantes aurait-il le plus de chance
que vous votiez et là on voit on voit un
RN très haut absolument et c'est vrai
que ça n'est le scénario que
d'aujourd'hui ça n'a pas valors de
pronostic pour les les élections
européennes mais ça montre un rapport de
force qui est très favorable au
rassemblement national et même plus
largement à l'extrême droite on a 31 %
des Français qui voteraient pour la
liste du rassemblement national contre
uniquement 21 % pour la liste de la
majorité présidentiel il y a 10 points
d'écart entre les deux mais il y en a
aussi 6 % qui voteraiit pour reconquête
la liste de
ça amènerait à 37% le total reconquête
plus rassemblement national et en tout
34 sièges au Parlement européen sur les
41 dont dispose la France la gauche en
aurait seulement 20 donc ça dit quand
même la droitisation et même l'extrême
droitisation si vous me permettez le mot
de du paysage politique sur cette
élection européenne c'est c'est un point
quand même à à à prendre en compte et
surtout cet écart de 10 points
impressionnant entre la majorité
présidentielle et le rassemblement
national qui passerait à 29 sièges il en
avait 23 en 2019 la majorité
présidentielle reculerait elle de de
trois sièges avec pourtant 2019 qui
était déjà une campagne européenne de
Nathalie Loiseau qui avait été vécu
comme une contreperformance par la
majorité la majorité estta arrivé juste
un point derrière le RN mais avec un
trend qui lui a été très défavorable ils
étaient partis beaucoup plus haut dans
les sondages jusqu'à baisser et passer
derrière le RN qui lui un peu monté donc
ils ont vraiment le le un dynamisme euh
une dynamique électoral autour de le RN
poussé par un double moteur à la fois
cette notabilisation dont on a parlé le
fait que des personnalités comme Marine
Le Pen Jordane Bardella Marion maréchal
s'instalent dans le paysage politique
deviennent fréquentable donc il y a il y
a cet effet notabilisation puis y a
l'effet actualité avec le poids des
questions de sécurité et d'immigration
aussi aujourd'hui qui les plac au cœur
du jeu politique mais ce qu'on voit
c'est que vraiment la dynamique
électorale est derrière eux sera
peut-tre ce sera peut-être pas parine Le
Pen en 2027 parce que tout le monde dit
ce sera elle ce sera elle moi je dis
juste je suis d'accord avec vous Émilie
on a ouvert la fenêre d'overton vous
savez c'éit c'est un symbole qui a été
théorisé par euh le juris du même nom
Overton aux États-Unis pour dire cette
fenêtre d'overton symbolise ce qui est
possible et ce qui est audible dans une
société euh dans le débat public là
aujourd'hui elle s'est complètement
ouverte on entend des choses acceptables
qui ne l'était pas il y a même 5 ans
notamment sur cette thématique de
l'immigration
c'est avec la tournée médiatique de
journal Bern ces derniers jours et ce
matin sur France Inter quand il dit je
suis prêt pour occuper Matignon la seule
les seuls arguments qu'on lui oppose sur
France interre c'est son âge trop jeune
passé d'expérience ça aurait été
impossible il y a quelques années on a
un ministre deéducation nationale qui a
33 ans donc c'est c'est possible le
jeunisme non mais effectivement il y a
une acceptation on va dire de
l'hypothèse du rassemblement national au
pouvoir qui qui était pas évidente il y
AEL ne serait-ce que quelques annes on
tort le coup à ce qui était acceptable
et peut-être qu'un populiste va arriver
à à la mille
argenttin c'est dans c'est dans
longtemps et les européennes c'est dans
7 mois donc là aussi il peut se passer
pas mal de choses mais quand même il
zapalski je retiens votre argument sur
le le le contexte il y a il y a le socle
puis y a le il y a finalement ce que
l'actualité apporte ou peut apporter au
rassemblement national est-ce que
c'était un risque de faire voter un
texte immigration maintenant ou est-ce
que finalement
euh c'était pas le seul moment pour le
faire parce que sinon après on était
encore plus près de de l'échéance éle
EUR avait l'avait un peu accéléré avait
accéléré son passage au moment de du
tragique événement à haras parce que le
contexte était plus porteur en fait pour
ça donc oui forcément ça facilite et à
mon avis il va pas avoir beaucoup de
choix que de continuer un peu là-dedans
justement quand on voit les sondages que
vous que vous donnez là sur les
élections européennes que de dire en
gros bah je suis obligé de montrer mes
muscles du côté de ces sujets là parce
que sinon c'est le RN c'est exactement
ce qu'a dit Gérald haranin il y a peu
sinon c'est le RN qui va être élu moi il
me semble qu'Emmanuel Macron il est
quand même il a essayé he tous les trucs
et on en a parlé le grand débat les
rencontres de de Saint-Denis il a essayé
le Conseil national de refondation le
référendum oui le référendum peut-être
que c'est ça et il serait urgent non
mais il ser il serait urgent en effet de
réouvrir un peu sur son en même temps si
c'est toujours un en même temps
équilibré ou alors c'est vraiment un
coming out sur un en même temps qui est
clairement à droite c'est ça c'est soit
il fait le choix de dire bah c'est bon
je suis parti beaucoup plus à droite que
je ne l'étais en 2017 soit il
rééquilibre sur des sujets et il y en a
pas mal et surtout s'il revenait sur les
sujets en plus il est assez bon
d'économie de réindustriisation
peut-être même c'est un gros mot mais
d'aménagement du territoire c'était le
sujet des gilets jaunes c'està-dire
métropole contre territoires ruraux pé
urbain il y a un vrai sujet en France
là-dessus parce que sur ces sujets là
même si le rassemblement national est
très bon etess parler à l'oreille des
territoires ruraux notamment qui avant
votaient plutôt Parti communiste ou
Parti socialiste et ben souvent quand on
les interrogent là-dessus ils sont
beaucoup moins bons pant que vous nous
parlez on voit le ministre de
l'Intérieur pardon qui est en train de
de de d'arriver dans dans dans
l'hémicycle ici au Sénat il y a une
courte interruption de séance et donc on
devrait avoir le vote sur cette
immigration dans quelques c'est
peut-être là où il pourrait montrer les
muscles ok sur les sujets de sécurité
immigration il durcit le ton est-ce
qu'il peut pas durcir le ton justement
c'est ce sujet de pouvoir d'achat
d'économie de réindustri
et autre gros mot sur l'écologie aussi
he parce que le rassemblement national
et l'écologie on est quand même très
loin donc il y a beaucoup d'endroits où
le potentiel du rassemblement national
n'est pas très ça ça effectivement ça
ouvre je trouve c'est vraiment très
intéressant ce que vous nous dites sur
la la marge on y revient la marge de
manœuvre Pascal Perino d'Emmanuel Macron
mais alors pas seulement là début
janvier quand il va prendre la parole
sur les textes qu'il peut proposer les
réformes qu'il peut impulser pour
éventuellement contrer le rassemblement
national alors je crois vous allez pas
pouvoir répondre à la question parce que
désolé Quentin vous reprenez la main euh
et voilà le premier vice-président LR
qui prés la séance merci à tous bonne
soirée pardon Pascal non non je vousen
prie la parole est à Madame Muriel
Jourda rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire pour 5
minutes m chers cègues s'il vous
plaît allez-y madame la rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministrees mes chers
collègues nous sommes ici effectivement
pour examiner les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenue aujourd'hui et hier sur le texte
de loi relatif à à
l'immigration la particularité de cette
commission mixte paritaire a été et vous
l'avez tous saisi que d'habitude nous
travaillons sur deux textes celui du
Sénat et celui de l'Assemblée nationale
mais que en réalité nous n'avions qu'un
texte comme document de travail qui
était celui qui émanait du Sénat tandis
que celui de l'Assemblée nationale
n'avait pas été adopté c'est dans ces
circonstances particulières qui me
semble-t-il impliquait que nous partions
comme base de travail du texte du Sénat
qui avait seul reçu l'onction
démocratique si je puis dire et une
onction assez large puisque je vous
rappelle que à 210 voix ce texte avait
été adopté c'est dans ces circonstances
particulières que nous avons débattu
dans le cadre de cette commission mixte
paritaire vous n'arez pas un grand
effort à faire pour comprendre quel est
le texte qui est issu de cette
commission mixte paritaire si ce n'est
un effort de mémoire puisque en réalité
il s'agit dans sa quasi intégralité du
texte que nous avions approuvé au
Sénat nous avons maintenu l'architecture
de notre texte qui comprenait je le
rappelle un titre totalement nouveau sur
la maîtrise des entrées de l'immigration
dans notre territoire qui comprenait un
volet sur l'intégration qui comprenait
un volet sur l'éloignement puis et j'y
passe rapidement
deux séries de dispositions plus
techniques l'une sur l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile et l'autre sur les
procédures judiciaires c'était surtout
la première architecture qui nous
intéressait c'est-à-dire le titre sur
l'entrée et nous avons globalement
conservé ce que je peux estime être un
acquis un acquis du Sénat d'abord le
débat au Parlement avec une fixation de
quotas ensuite un affermissement des
proc dure sur différents titres le
regroupement familial le titre étranger
malade mais également le titre étudiant
avec un un meilleur contrôle nous avions
aussi obtenu me semble-t-il une
amélioration sur l'aide médicale d'État
sur ce point nous avons acquis de madame
la Première ministre par un courrier
écrit envoyé à à président Larcher le
fait que ce débat reprendrait à la
lumière aussi du rapport evvin
stéphanini rapport qui n'était pas
inintéressant il faut le dire dans les
mois qui viennent pour que nous
puissions assurer un meilleur contrôle
de l'aide médicale d'État et je prends
je reprends sur ce point les propos de
madame la Première ministre qui ont été
écrits nous avions donc
maintenu cet aspect qui est une
meilleure maîtrise de l'entrée sur notre
territoire par les étrangers et il me
semble que c'est un point extrêmement
important en tout cas nous le soulevons
avec Monsieur philiip boncarer
corapporteur à chaque fois depuis qu
temps que nous avons traité le budget
sur l'immigration le deuxème point est
celui sur l'intégration et c'est un
point également important où il est
acquis me semble-t-il désormais qu'une
meilleure acquisition de la langue
française sera demandée à ceux qui
veulent vivre durablement en France dans
le cadre d'une carte de séjour
plurannuelle mais également à ceux qui
veulent venir dans le cadre d'un
regroupement familial qui devront avoir
aussi un niveau de langue conséquent un
examen civique est également demandé qui
permettra à ceux qui veulent vivre chez
nous et bien de mieux comprendre quel
est notre pays et donc de mieux s'y
intégrer et de mieux s'y adapter on leur
demandera aussi par un contrat de
respecter les principes de la République
les étrangers qui viennent en France
respectent tout simplement la France on
parle la langue et on connaissent
l'histoire et l'esprit civique cela me
semble nécessaire l'intégration par le
travail avait été abordée nous avons
longuement discuté de ce point à
l'article 3 l'article 4 bis je n'y
reviens que pour vous dire que c'est
l'article 4 bis qui a été conservé pas
de prime à la fraude nous donc une
régularisation qui se fera dans le cadre
d'une admission exceptionnelle au séjour
l'état conserve la maîtrise de la
politique migratoire et enfin ce volet
éloignement dont je vous ai parlé a été
totalement maintenu avec une
facilitation de l'éloignement finalement
de ceux qui causent des troubles à
l'ordre publique sur le territoire
français et en cela je pense que nous
serons tous d'accord enfin a été rajouté
un titre entier sur les outres m au
Sénat nous avons je crois un intérêt
particulier pour les outres mères nous
l'avons maintenu et nous avons dans le
cadre de cette cmt ajoué ajouter ce
titre voilà mes chers collègues ce que
nous avons fait sommairement car le
temps ne me permet pas de vous en dire
plus sIIT que je crois que par ce texte
nous nous attaquons à un problème qui
est essentiel pour nos compatriotes nous
le faisons d'une façon qui me paraît
extrêmement raisonnable mais qui se veut
efficace et qui j'espère sera efficace
si les conclusions cette commission
mixte paritaire sont adopté et c'est
pourquoi dans la mesure où il s'agit peu
ou prou du texte que nous avons
précédemment voté je demande à tous ceux
qui l'avait voté nous étions 210 à voter
à nouveau les conclusions de cette
commission mixte paritaire je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Gérald dararmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
outremèes
monsieur le Président Monsieur Madame la
Ministre cher Sabrina monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs pour le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outrever
que je suis après plus d'un an de
discussion autour d'un texte important
et s'il avait été discret je crois qu'il
ne l'est plus après divers discussions
parlementaire nous arrivons au but et
j'espère que votre assemblée comme celle
de l'Assemblée nationale le votera pour
pouvoir protéger les Français mieux
intégrer les étrangers simplifier la vie
administrative mais aussi il faut le
dire mais ici il faut le dire améliorer
des dispositions qui n'étaient pas prévu
dans le texte initial du gouvernement le
texte du Sénat n'est pas le texte qui
remplace le texte du Gouvernement mais
qui le
complète sur 27
articles sur 27 articles un seul a été
retiré
sur 27 articles initiaux du projet du
gouvernement un seul a été retiré celui
l'article 4 qui prévoyait que les de
demandeur d'asile avant 6 mois sur le
arrivé sur le sol national pouvaent
travailler tous les autres ont été
maintenus la plupart dans leur
intégralité parfois avec des
modifications mineures d'autresfis avec
des modifications plus substantielles
mais dont l'esprit est resté le
gouvernement le gouvernement tenait et
je crois la majorité de l'Assemblée
nationale avec lui si je vrais saluer le
groupe de François patria et de Claude
maluret qui nous ont soutenu dans cette
action tenit à l'équilibre de son
texte premier équilibre de ce texte
était évidemment l'intégration des
personnes
étrangères beaucoup de dispositions
autour de la langue notamment l'examen
de français obligatoir pour les titres
pluriannuels des dispositions autour du
travail et je voudrais dire ici que si
le Sénat le vote je crois qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de doute si l'Assemblée
nationale le vote il y aura donc pour la
première fois il y aura donc il y aura
donc pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la République dans la loi
une mesure législative de régularisation
qui comme l'a souhaité le gouvernement
coupe le lien entre employeur et
employés pour pouvoir connaître cette
régularisation et touchera des milliers
de personnes d'après le gouvernement
entre 7 à 10000 personnes
supplémentaires qui dans les métiers en
tenstion mérite de sortir de
l'hypocrisie dans laquelle nous les
plongeons collectivement depuis tant de
gouvernements pour connaître évidemment
le monde normal classique quand on paye
des cotisations quand on paye des impôts
il est normal de se voir reconnaître en
effet un titre de séjour sur le un titre
de séjour sur le sol de la République et
je m'étonne que la gauche ne le voit pas
sans
doute sans doute regrettant de ne la pas
fait de pas l'avoir fait elle-même chers
collègues deuxème sujet deème équilibre
du texte du Gouvernement c'était
évidemment un lien très fort qu'il y
avait entre d'un côté le fait qu'il
fallait être à l'écoute de l'intégration
et plus exigeant d'un certain point de
vue et de l'autre plus dur contre la
délinquence étrangère et les criminels
étrangers de ce point de vue je crois
que le travail parlementaire qu'on a eu
notamment avec le Sénat mais aussi la
CMP a permis d'améliorer les dispositifs
du gouvernement mais qui pour la
première fois depuis 25 ans reviennent
sur les protections qu'on a appelé
Jadice la fin de la double peine et
permettent enfin de pouvoir expulser les
délinquants étrangers du S national ou
de leur retirer leur titre de séjour
parce qu'ils adhèrent à une idéologie
radicale ou parce qu'ils sont contre les
droits de la République en même temps si
j'ose dire que les délinquants étrangers
qui doivent être combattu pour la
première fois dans la loi de la
République et après 50 ans de demande
d'à peu près tout le monde associatif et
de tous les partis politiques de gauche
mais qui ne le font jamais lorsqu'ils
sont en responsabilité pour la première
fois nous allons nous allons pour la
première fois nous allons interdire le
placement des enfants des mineurs dans
les centres de rétention administrative
et dans tous les lieu de rétention
administrative et on le Deva au
gouvernement on le devra au président de
la République et à ceux qui le voteront
dans quelques instants ce sera une
grande avancée qui devrait me
semble-t-il attirer l'attention de
quelquesuns sur le troisième sujet qui
est un sujet monsieur le président de la
commission des lois et je le regrette
très important sans doute le plus
important mais qui n'a pas fait floresse
dans les les débats médiatiques ni
parlementaires la simplification de
procédures administratives inspiré
directement votre rapport monsieur le
Président lui-même inspiré du rapport de
Monsieur Stal au Conseil d'État je pense
que nous armons profondément notre
justice administrative dans la
simplification 12 procédures passées à 3
là encore deux titres très importants
des dizaines d'articles un droit
complètement changé pour l'instant ça
n'a pas fait la une des journaux
j'espère que ça le fera demain mais je
pense que c'est un vu pieux 3e et 4e
pardon et dernier sujet le gouvernement
a donc pris acte d'abord du travail qu'a
fait le Sénat et je veux ici remercier
l'ensemble des sénateurs de tous les
groupes puisque nous avons pris des
amendements de tous les groupes de tous
les groupes et bien sûr ceux de la
majorité sénatoriale et de la majorité
présidentielle nous n'étions pas
d'accord sur tout nous étions dit mais
je voudrais dire que je crois que vous
avez vu un gouvernement qui était à
l'écoute des dispositions souhaité et
d'ailleurs des partis ou des groupes de
la majorité parlementaire à l'Assemblée
qui vous ont soutenu puisque monsieur
Pat monsieur maluré ont voté
favorablement à ce texte je veux faire
remarquer d'ailleurs qu'alors que le
texte du Sénat est à une version plus
dure puisque nous avons modifié 15
article en CMP et que nous avons retiré
laame que nous avons retiré la fin de
l'hébergement d'urgence on va l'appeler
comme ça pour la rapidité du discours
alors que nous avons mis évidemment dans
la loi les métiers en tenstion alors que
nous avons mis jusqu'à 18 ans la fin
déplacement des mineurs en centre de
rétention administratif alors que nous
avons prévu une exception pour la
caution pour les éant étrangers
particulièrement méritant euh bien sûr
alors que nous avons largement euh
raboté une mesure sur les prestations
sociales on en reparlera si vous le
souhaitez passant de 5 ans à 3 mois ou
de 5 ans à zéro pour la plupart de ceux
qui travaillent je voudrais remarquer
ici que les deux sénateurs du rassemblé
national ont voté contre ce texte
et permettez-moi de m'attirer
l'attention sur un point précis voilà
donc voilà donc un drôle de moment
parlementaire ou un texte qui est
version on va dire plus dure plus dure
que que propose le gouvernement qui est
plus dure que la version qui est
présentée aujourd'hui chacun doit faire
un pas vers l'autre et je pense que
c'est le principe d'un accord
parlementaire quand un texte est dur
réputé comme dur les deux sénateurs du
rassemblement national ne votent pas bon
tout augmente tout augmente vous avez
raison monsieur le Président
rillot les sénateurs du rassemblement
national ne vote pas ce texte
considérant qu'il y a des
régularisations considérant qu'il ne
répond à rien considérant qu'il ne sert
à rien
attant les centrist attaquant la
majorité parlementaire et puis quand
Madame Le Pen voit le jour se lever
comme le CO de Chanteclair là elle se
dit tiens quel petit coup politique je
peux faire ça dupe personne grâce à
l'action du Sénat grâce à l'action du
Sénat et du gouvernement nous aurons un
texte pour protéger les
Français alors il est vrai comme le
disait le le général de gale sur
l'essentiel nous
pouvons mais je sais que vous l'avez
combattu toute votre vie c'est pas la
peine maintenant qu'il est maintenant
qu'il n'est plus là de vous reprocher le
général de Gaulle mais sur l'essentiel
sur l'essentiel nous pouvons nous
retrouver et je veux dire au sénateur de
l'anupes je veux dire au sénateur de
l'anupes s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues je veux dire au sénateur de
l'anupes c'est pas non plus c'est pas
non plus une insulte c'est pas non plus
une insulte
mes chers collègues s'il vous plaît
chaque groupe aura l'occasion de
s'exprimer laissez le ministre
s'exprimer que les partis qui adhèrent à
la
nuègues se sont déshonorés en demandant
le vote du rassemblé national sur la MO
de Roger empêchant bien évidemment
empêchant évidemment le débat
parlementaire
classique mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le président de la République
la première ministre et le gouvernement
a prés un texte courageux et chacun le
constate un texte
difficile il a dit dès le début qu'il ne
procéderait pas à l'adoption de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 afin de permettre
des débats et il a tenu
parole il a dit dès le début qu'il
chercherait le plus possible dans des
conditions qu'il n pas tout à fait
imaginé comme cellelà bien évidemment un
accord avec tous ceux qui voulaient
travailler pour le bien et la protection
des Français
non mais vous pouvez parler du rassemblé
national le RN ici a voté contre aucune
disposition n'a été négociée avec eux
ils sont contre les
quotas chers collègues s'il vous plaî
ils sont contre les quotas ils sont
contre les régularisations ils sont
contre la fin des mineurs dans les
centres de rétention administratif ils
sont contre les passeports talent ils
sont contre les mesures sur
l'hébergement ils sont contre les
mesures qui conc
ils sont contre l'intégralité des
dispositions puisquells ont connu à
trois exceptions près des votes contre
en commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de l'anupes regardez les
choses et soyez bonjoueurs il y a un
accord politique qui ne satisfait
personne un accord qui ne satisfait
personne totalement mais qui permet à
chacune et à chacun de se retrouver sur
l'essentiel la protection des Français
je ne seraai pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui pour vous faire plaisir
fera la politique du pire et désarmera
les policiers les gendarmes et les
[Musique]
magistrats dans ce contexte monsieur le
Président le gouvernement qui n'a pas
utilisé le 493 qui a laissé le débat
venir jusqu'à la fin qui a
renvoyé qui a renvoyé qui a renvoyé le
texte du Sénat puisque l'assemblée n'a
pas voulu en discuter malgré le travail
très important fait en commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale en
commission mix paritaire a tout fait je
crois qu'on peut le dire avec le groupe
centriste avec le groupe DLR avec le
groupe de Monsieur maluré groupe de
patri pour trouver le meilleur accord
possible bien sûr bien sûr il y a des
questions encore autour de ce texte
chacuns je veux le dire ici monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
c'est pas faire un jour au Sénat et nous
en avons parlé librement bien sûr dans
cet hémicycle les débats en fond foi des
mesures sont manifestement et clairement
contraires à la
Constitution le travail du Conseil
constitutionnel fera son office mais la
politique ce n'est pas être juristes
avant les juristes la politique est
d'élaborer des normes et de constater si
elles sont ou pas d'après nous conformes
et oui des questions se posent sur un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
pourrai être soit non conventionnelles
soit peu constitutionnel mais laissons
le Conseil constitutionnel faire son
affaire je veux dire ici qu m intérieur
et des autres maires j'appliquerai bien
évidemment non seulement la lettre de la
loi qui sera promulguée par le Président
de la République et par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais également l'esprit
avec lequel nous avons travaillé tous
ensemble mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il est évident qu'être
ministre de l'Intérieur et présenté un
texte alors qu'on a une majorité
relative dans des conditions médiatiques
politiques que nous connaissons n'est
pas la chose la plus facile mais mais je
suis certain qu'ici et là les Français
dans leur immense majorité voient que
nous avons pris nos responsabilités et
venant par deux fois venant par deux
fois de deux familles immigrées qui sont
arrivées sur le sol français étant élu
moi-même dans un territoire que
qualifier de gauche où Monsieur
Mélenchon et laanupè font 34 % au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans ma commune je
constate que je n'ai aucune leçon à
recevoir voir de brevet de morale elle
ne se fait pas saint-jamain de près elle
se fait dans l'hémicycle pour
l'Assemblée nationale et dans le
Sénat
merci merci mes chers collègues je
rappelle qu'en application de l'article
42 alineéa 12 du règlement le Sénat
statue par un seul vote sur l'ensemble
du texte nous passons aux explications
de vote des groupes en raison d'un
orateur par groupe la parole est à
présent à Monsieur Michel Masset pour le
groupe RDSE pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur euh le président
monsieur le ministre la ministre
mesdames madames et monsieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers
collègues deux questions qui requièrent
notre attention aujourd'hui
d'abord celle de la méthode
d'élaboration de ce texte au cours de la
navette ensuite celle du fond et de la
position de notre Parlement au sujet de
l'immigration en premier lieu concernant
la méthode le groupe RDSE
s'interroge nous aimons rappeler à cette
tribune notre attachement au débat
parlementaires comme essence de nos
régimes démocratique et rép
républicain priver nos hémicycles de
délibération d'échang voir de
controversse c'est s'exposer au risque
de dévoyer et pervertir l'expression
même de la volonté générale renoncer au
débat c'est faire un pas vers
l'arbitraire vers un monde de décision
si symptomatique ancien et qui avait
justifié différentes étapes de notre de
notre
histoire il a donc été décidé que seul
le Sénat
examinerait disposition par
disposition chacun des articles du
projet de
loi le groupe RDSE avait dit sa position
à l'issue de l'examen nous étions
majoritairement contre la rédaction
sénatoriale mais nous acceptons les
règles du jeu
démocratique à l'Assemblée nationale une
majorité était contre saura-ton pourquoi
au motif de la la suppression de laame
ou bien de la mise en place d'un titre
de séjour Béti en tenstion pas de débat
pas de
réponse nous voilà aujourd'hui avec un
nouveau texte débattu à H clos et
négocié un lapse de temps restreint
contreint la réunion de la CMP aura
réussi à durer plus longtemps que
l'examen devant la Chambre
basse j'imagine que c'est inédite dans
notre Histoire parlementaire il demeure
que comme jeune sénateur je suis aussi
étonné que préoccupé en découvrant cette
méthode la Constitution le permet soit
les rouages du parlementarisme
rationalisé prouvent leur efficacité
jusqu'à des situations démocratiquement
excusez-moi absurdes nous gardons donc
la liberté de ne pas nous satisfaire
d'un tel
cheminement nous n'aurons finalement
qu'à peine quelques minutes pour
découvrir le détail de la nouvelle
version du projet autant dire que notre
connaissance tient pour beaucoup aux
article de presse ou autres là encore
c'est
insatisfaisant malgré ça puisque'un
texte nous est présenté il me faut tout
de même aborder le
fond celui initial du gouvernement avait
plutôt tendance à nous satisfaire
monsieur le
ministre deux personnes alors en
revanche la tournure de nos débats au
Sénat avait fait pencher une majorité
des membres notre groupe à voté contre
et les autres s'étant
abstenu nous étions unanimement contre
pardon la suppression de laame
elle ne figure pas dans le nouveau texte
tant mieux il s'agissait pour nous d'une
ligne
infranchissable il y avait aussi la
question des titres de séjour pour les
travailleurs sans papier la version
sénatoriale semble l'avoir emporté sur
le dispositif initial proposé par le
gouvernement nous le regrettons les
articles 3 et 4 constituent à nos yeux
une avancée utile et efficace certes à
perfaire ou à parfaire en début persiste
également dans le texte l'instauration
de cotas migratoirees le durcissement
des règles du regroupement familial le
durcissement des règles relatives à
l'immigration étudiante le
conditionnement du bénéfice de certaines
prestations sociales non contributives à
une durée minimale de séjour régulier le
rétablissement du délou du délit pardon
du séjour irrégulier ou encore la
restriction du droit du sol pour l'accès
à la nationalité bon bien sûr il n'y a
pas que cela le texte comprend également
des mesures attendues en matière
d'application des
otf je pense aussi à la réforme du
contentieux des étrangers ou bien au
durcissement des sanctions pénales en
cas d'exploitation des migrants cela
étant malgré ses
dispositions la majorité des membres de
notre groupe persistera à voter contre
ce
texte je vous remercie la parole est à
présent à notre collègue Olivier Bitz
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes indépendants
pour 5
minutes merci Monsieur le le Président
Madame et Monsieur les ministres
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madamees et monsieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues le projet de loi
contrôler l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration voulu par le gouvernement
répondit à l'exigence d'adaptation de
notre droit aux nouvelles réalités que
notre pays connaî dans le domaine
migratoire la situation demande en effet
aujourd'hui de mieux réguler les flux de
mieux protéger les Français contre les
délinquants étrangers et de mieux
intégrer grâce à l'affirmation de nos
valeurs au travail et à l'usage de notre
langue des étrangers aant vocation à
rester sur le territoire national au
sein de notre assemblée saisi en
première lecture les débats ont été
riches et constructifs ils ont permis
l'adoption d'un texte que la majorité du
groupe RDPI a voté validant ainsi une
démarche de de construction qui devait
se poursuivre dans le cadre la navette
parlementaire car oui je l'avais exprimé
à cette tribune certaines disposition
contenue dans le texte voté par notre
assemblée ne nous convenait pas et notre
vote positif ne valait pas quitus il en
était ainsi tout particulièrement pour
la suppression de
laame le travail législatif était
néanmoins bien lancé pour doter notre
pays de la législation dont il a
besoin malheureusement une coalition
aussi étrange qu'éteréroclite a vu le
jour à l'Assemblée nationale pour mettre
en difficulté le gouvernement et
finalement provoquer une brusque
accélétion des échanges qui aurait dû en
toute hypothèse avoir lieu entre nos
deux chambres notre groupe a abordé
cette commission mixte paritaire en
ayant toujours la même priorité à
l'esprit aboutir à un texte équilibré
qui soit une réponse efficace au besoins
du pays et aux attentes des Français un
accord était impératif pas seulement
pour le gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle pas seulement pour l'ELR
mais pour le pays tout entier ces
échanges nous les avons eu sous le
regard attentif des français puisque 67
% d'entre eux se sont déclarés
favorables à ce texte sur
l'immigration cependant chacun
s'accordait pour dire que certaines des
dispositions votées par le Sénat comme
certaines dispositions votées par la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nécessité d'être
réécrite s'agissant de
l'Ame nous avons tenu compte à la CMP
des conclusion sans équivoque du rapport
rédigé par msieur stéphanini et Evin ce
rapppport estime que l'aide médical
d'État est utile et maîtrisé c'est ce
qui nous a conduit à revenir sur la
souppression de laame proposé par le
texte du Sénat compte tenu de
l'engagement de notre première ministre
d'engager dans les meilleurs délais une
réforme concernant les prestations
sociales le texte du Sénat conditionnit
toutes les aides non contributives à une
résidence de 5 ans sur le territoire
national elles ont été réduites les les
les délis à la fois ont été réduits et
les périmètres également les périmètres
des a
concerné s'agissant de la nationalité
nous avons supprimé C articles qui à nos
yeux étaient problématiqu restera par
contre et nous l'assumons la déchéance
de nationalité pour les binationaux
condamnés pour homicide sur personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique pour
l'hébergement d'urgence là encore le
texte du CTA n'était pas vraiment
applicable en l'état il faut bien le
dire car il risquait de mettre à la rue
plus de 150000 personnes du jour au
lendemain pour l'obtention du titre de
séjours étranger malade enfin nous nous
en resterons à la rédaction de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale à nos ux plus justes et plus
équilibré compte tenu des débats
constructifs et du texte auquel nous
avons réussi à aboutir en commission
mixte paritaire sous l'égide de nos
rapporteurs sous l'égide des deux
présidents de les des commissions des
des lois de nos assemblées notre groupe
votera dans sa majorité pour le projet
de loi présenter les conclusions de CMP
je vous
remercie merci la parole est à présent
au président Patrick canner pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madamees et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues depuis hier nous avons eu avec
mes collègues Marie-Pierre la Gonterie
et Corine rassigin la charge et
l'honneur de porter dans cette CMP
certes les propositions de notre groupe
mais surtout la défense d'une certaine
idée des valeurs de notre pays dans son
histoire la France s'est construite avec
l'apport et la contribution des
populations étrangères parfois même au
prix de leur sang et c'est aussi
Monsieur le Ministre un fils d'immigré
qui vous le dit ce soir aujourd'hui
encore sans les travailleurs étrangers
les hôpitaux où vous vous faites soigner
les aides à domicile qui prennent soins
de vos parents les maisons que vous
faites construire le supermarché vous
faites vos courses et bien sans les
immigrés rien de tout cela ne pourrait
fonctionner et vous le
savez
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est à eux que je pense ce soir à
chacune de ces personnes qui ont fait le
choix souvent contraint de s'installer
sur notre sol diffonder leur famille d'y
construire une nouvelle vie car il
s'agit bien de cela de vie humaine avant
tout qui mérite respect et
considération quand le 11 janvier
dernier j'ai reçu au Sénat messieurs
dermanin et duopt ceci avaient vanté
l'équilibre de leur projet de loi il
s'agissait alors de mieux contrôler
l'immigration mais aussi de faciliter
l'intégration des étrangers dans notre
pays ce soir je le constate amèrement
cette promesse était un leure pour dire
les choses clairement ce texte sur
lequel nous sommes amenés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui est un texte de
police des étrangers dans la quête d'un
électorat perdu le gouvernement et la
droite ont choisi de se fondre dans la
rhtorique que seule l'extrême droite
défendait jusqu'alors la France au
français je vous le dis comme je le
pense la violence de ce texte nous
heurte ce texte est une honte d'heure en
heure de recul en recul de marchandage
en marchandage la droite a entraîné une
majorité présidentielle complaisante
dans un ravin populiste sous l'œil Gour
our de l'extrême droite en toute
logique en toute
logique cette extrême droite votera ce
projet de loi ce projet de loi elle
aurait même pu l'écrire cette extrême
droite Rance haineuse qui se frotte les
mains en contemplant ce spectacle cette
marée brune qui fait sauter toutes les
digues les unes après les autres mes
chers
collègues mes chers collègues je suis
inquiet pour mon pays pour son avenir
que reste-t-il de nos valeurs de nos
idéaux de la France pays des droits de
l'homme par deux fois Emmanuel Macron
est arrivé au pouvoir car nous car nous
étions nombreux à espérer qu'il fasse
barrage à l'extrême droite aujourd'hui
le même Emmanuel Macron amène les idées
d'extrême droite au pouvoir je
m'adresse je m'adresse aux
parlementaires qui de bonne foi ont cru
en même temps du président de la
République ouvrez les yeux en 2027
allez-vous assum d'avoir donné corps aux
pires excès de l'extrême droite
assumerez-vous d'avoir gravé la
préférence nationale dans le marbre de
la loi assumerez-vous d'avoir privé les
étrangers en situation régulière ainsi
que leurs enfants de moyens de
subsistance pendant plusieurs années
assumerez-vous d'avoir mis à terre les
principes de la nationalité
assumerez-vous d'avoir imposé aux
étudiants des conditions inatteignables
pour rejoindre nos universités
assumerez-vous d'avoir réduit les
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
à de simples variables d' justement
assumerez-vous de n'avoir pas fermé la
porte à la remise en cause de l'aide
médicale d'État les dispositions que
vous avez voté depuis hier soir sont une
insulte à nos lumières comment
d'ailleurs nos collègues centristes
comment nos collègues centristes depuis
la première lecture au Cénat peuvent-ils
accepter de prêter la main à une telle
dérive extrémiste à rebour de leur
propre histoire non mes chers collègues
un étranger n'est pas paressence un
danger pour notre civilisation notre
mode de vie not notre activité
économique vous vous êtes laissé
submerger par des fantasmes d'un autre
temps non seulement vous renoncez à nos
valeurs fondatrices mais avec ce texte
vous ajoutez du désordre au désordre le
droit des étrangers s'ans pile des
enfants non accompagnés sont à la rue
des situations d'étrangers sont examinés
de manière partielle et partiale les otf
sont délivrées n'importe comment elles
ne sont pas appliquées mes chers
collègues ce 1912 marque l'entrée de la
droite et du centre dans la majorité
présidentielle au risque de leur propre
disparition ce 19 décembre sonne la
rupture de la digue défendue pendant de
nombreuses années par la droite
française contre l'extrême droite ce 19
décembre le Front républicain a fait
long feu vous avez inventé la
cohabitation d'opportunités la coalition
sans contrat la collision la collusion
du renoncement mais rappelez-vous les
Français préféreront toujours l'original
à la copie vous êtes vainqueur peut-être
ce soir mais êtes-vous vraiment les
bénéficiaires de cette victoire vous
avez choisi de tourner le dos à ce beau
con
des v mieux vaut perdre une élection que
perdre son âme je termine rassurez-vous
un vent mauvais souffle sur notre
territoire pour notre part en gardant la
nuide nous voterons contre ce projet de
loi
immigration la parole est à présent au
président François Noël buffet pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame le rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues les
donneurs de leçons de ce soir qu'il soit
de gauche ou d'extrême droite ont oublié
qu'il y a quelques années ils avaient
mis en commun leur connivance sous la
présidence du président mitteron pour
faire émerger le Front national ils
l'ont
oublié c'est
vous c'est vous qui avez perdu la
mémoire c'est vous qui avez perdu la
mémoire et pourtant ce soir vous osez
encore nous donner des leçons moi je
voudrais simplement dire à cette
tribune que au début des débats sur ce
texte sur l'immigration le gouvernement
est venu avec son texte faisait 27
articles que la commission des lois l'
travaillé la majorité sénatoriale l'a
travaillé en compagnie d'autres
collègues qui se sont
naturellement attachés à faire
progresser ce texte et nous avons
aujourd'hui un texte d'un peu plus de 80
articles ce n'est pas la quantité qui
fait la qualité mais c'est d'abord la
stratégie qu'il est important c'est
d'abord la stratégie qu'il est important
de rappeler nous assumons totalement les
choix qui ont été faits ils ne viennent
pas de nulle part ils viennent d'un
travail de longue haleine qui a été
effectué dans cette maison qui a été
effectué par notre
mouvement c'est le fruit de rapport
issus d'ailleurs de la commission des
lois c'est le fruit de propositions qui
sont venu d'autres horizons d'autres
collègues bien évidemment c'est le fruit
aussi c'est le fruit aussi d'un travail
acharné d'une vision quelle était cette
vision c'est la cohérence d'abord de
maîtriser l'immigration irrégulière de
ne pas rester
finalement passif par rapport à ce à ce
qui se passe c'est le choix de lutter
fermement contre l'immigration
irrégulière en considérant que la
tolérance devait être de zéro ni plus ni
moins c'est la tolérance l'objectif
aussi de protéger contrairement à ce
qu'on imagine la procédure d'asile
régulièrement détourné et je dis bien
protéger la procédure d'asile qui est en
train de vivre de sombres moments parce
qu'elle est utilisée par les réseaux
mafieux à son détriment et au détriment
de ceux qui qui mérite la protection au
détriment de ceux qui méritent la
protection et puis c'est bien sûr la
simplification des procédures la
simplification des procédures
contentieuses qui dans ce texte vont
permettre enfin à nos magistrats à notre
administration de fonctionner
normalement bien sûr que nous avons
travaillé sur d'autres sujets on n parle
plus aujourd'hui on se concentre de
quelques points mais la réalité
rappelez-vous c'est tout le travail sur
le débat annuel sur les sujets
d'immigration c'est tout le respect des
valeurs de la République qui ont été
réintroduites dans ce texte c'est tous
le sujets sur l'apprentissage de la
langue vous ne parlez que de ce qui ne
marche pas moi je parle de ce qui est
positif et nous parlons de ce qui est
positif en faveur évidemment de
l'intégration qui doit être le sujet
absolument partagé alors la CMP a une
particularité elle a une spécificité
c'est que le texte issu de nos rangs ici
au Sénat largement voté n'a pas trouvé
finalement de contradictoire en face de
lui à l'Assemblée nationale puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu de texte et vous vous avez
d'ailleurs allègrement mê les vos
voix à ceux que vous combattez
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas hésité vous
n'avez pas hésité une seconde pas une
seconde alors les leçons de morale ça
suffit alors je voudis vous dire que
nous n'avons pas eu à l'assembbllée
nationale monsieal la parole est au
président buffet et à lui seul nous
sommes retrouvver à l'Assemblée
nationale avec une case vide pas de
texte et le texte qui fait référence
c'est le nôtre il a fait il a été le
fruit d'un travail et de discussion avec
nos contradicteurs de l'Assemblée
nationale avec les rapporteurs monsieur
le ministre madame la ministre que vous
aviez à l'Assemblée nationale un travail
de fond approfondi on a discuté on a
fait évoluer les choses on a tenu compte
de leur demande et on est arrivé à un
accord au bout de ces discussions certes
elles ont été longues et alors que nous
aurait-ons reproché si nous avions bâlé
les opérations
elles ont été longues elles ont été
mentenées correctement et nous
aboutissons à ce texte ce soir je
voudrais vous dire puisque le temps est
effectivement assez bref qu'il faudrait
rappeler deux trois choses en
particulier une peut-être de trois mais
une parce que le temps m'est
compté dans cette
maison le rassemblement national n'a pas
voté le texte nous avons entendu pendant
des semaines et des semaines qu'il était
le texte le plus abominable du monde
qu'il était même pas suffisamment dur
et ce soir on vient essayer de faire un
hold up sur ce texte mais ce n'est pas
votre texte ce n'est pas vos idées ce
sont les nôtres et uniquement les nôtres
et c'est donc le texte ce soir de la
commission mixpitaire qui résulte d'un
accord avec la majorité de l'Assemblée
nationale et qui est le résultat j'en
termine monsieur le Président qui est le
résultat d'un travail de longue haleine
je le redis qui a été je voudrais
remercier les collègues du groupe groupe
LR les collègues du groupe centriste et
tous ceux qui sont associés à ce travail
merci et c'est merci à vous merci
monsieur le Président
[Musique]
buffet mes chers collègues la parole est
à
présent à Monsieur Christopher zourk
pour les sénateurs ne figurant sur la
liste d'aucun groupe pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur monsieur
le ministre chers collègues nous y voilà
donc nous le savions tous avant
d'engager ce long chemin parlementairire
nos compatriotes attendent désespérément
des mesures réelles pour arrêter la
submersion migratoire qui assaille notre
pays les effets destructeur de
l'immigration dérégulé sur notre pays ne
sont plus à démontrer ce texte devait
ainsi répondre à ce défi fondamental
pour notre pays pour notre pour nos
compatriotes l'absence de prise de
conscience réelle du problème migratoire
depuis 50 ans a entraîné une situation
insupportable alors que nous accueillons
500000 entrées légales et illégales par
an la France s'ouvre d'une immigration
profondément inadapté aux besoins de
notre économie et au vœux de nos
compatriotes loin d'être cette
immigration de travail qui pourvoirait
les soi-disant emplois abandonnés par
les Français le phénomène migratoire
actuel est une charge que nous ne
pouvons plus assumer ni d'un point de
vue économique ni d'un point de vue
politique social culturel sécuritaire
démographique et j'iraai même jusqu'à
dire morale cette loi accouché au force
s'est passé par les fourches codines de
l'hystérisation médiatique et
parlementaire était une belle promesse
exence culturelle limitation de l'accès
inconditionnel aux prestations sociales
non contributives simplification du du
contentieux des étrangers création d'un
délit de séjour irrégulier réforme de
l'accès à la nationalité ces objectifs
le rassemblement national les partageent
mais surtout nos compatriotes les
demandent alors ce texte n'est pas
parfait il reste bien en de ça de ce que
nous souhaitons mais il a au moins
permis de remettre au centre du débat la
priorité nationale que nous appelons de
No
depuis quelques jours la gauche montre
au créneau pour dénoncer la priorité
nationale la qualifiant de mesures
racistes inhumaine antirépublicaine
avant d'être porté par le FN et le RN la
priorité nationale était une mesure
défendue par la gauche contre le
capitalisme qui souhaitait constituer
son armée de réserve exploitable à merci
et à bas prix le Front populaire
lui-même prit des décrets pour limiter
l'apport de main d'œuvre étrangère et
lutter contre l'immigration illégale et
de Salang grro à marché cette priorité
fut défendue mes chers collègues la
priorité nationale n'est pas une
exclusion c'est faire le choix des
nôtres avant les autres c'est l'idée que
nos compatriotes d'où qu'ils viennent
sont au cœur de nos préoccupations et
sont la priorité de nos combats et nous
ne laissons personne salir ce qui
devrait être le sacerdoce de tout élu de
notre République Monsieur le Ministre
j'ai bien conscience que vous essayez de
faire croire que vous avez encore la
main et que ce texte est bien le vôtre
mais aujourd'hui la représentation
nationale l'emporte sur le gouvernement
après des mois de mépris à trou joué on
perd parfois cela servira peut-être de
leçon à un exécutif qui a cru pouvoir
malmener le pouvoir législatif quoi
qu'il en soit aujourd'hui fidèle à nos
engagements de défendre nos compatriotes
de soutenir tous les projets qui iraient
dans le sens de leurs intérêts d'où
qu'ils viennent nous voterons ce texte
de concert avec nos collègue à
l'Assemblée nationale pour le reste nous
payons pas de mot seul une réforme
constitutionnelle et un référendum sur
l'immigration répondront réellement aux
aspirations des Français et nous
continuerons de le demander je vous
remercie
la parole est à présent à Monsieur Louis
Vogel pour le groupe les indépendants
pour 5
minutes mes chers collègues s'il vous
plaît monsieur
tal monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madame et
monsieurs les rapporteurs monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers
collègues au même titre que le reste du
continent notre pays fait face
aujourd'hui à un afflux migratoire
majeur nos partenaires européens ont
pris diverses mesures pour y faire face
la Finlande a fermé sa frontière russe
le Danemark a envisagé de renvoyer ses
migrants au
Rwanda il faut dire que la Turquie la
Biélorussie la Russie n'hésitent pas à
employer les flus migratoires comme arme
géopolitique contre
l'Europe nos concitoyens sont 71 % à
considérer que l'immigration est trop
importante en France dans ces conditions
nous devions
légiférer il fallait mettre un terme au
détournement manifeste de notre droit
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
commission des lois mettre en œuvre une
immigration choisie sur la base de cota
et reconduire à la frontière ceux qui
n'ont pas leur place dans notre pays
nous nous réjouissons au groupe des
indépendants que la commission mixte
paritaire soit parvenue à un
accord l'équilibre général du texte issu
du Sénat a été
respecté il oriente notre pays vers une
immigration
choisie le Parlement a fait ce choix en
précisant d'abord ce qu'il voulait un
flux d'immigration mieux contrôlé
notamment à travers l'instauration de
quota le texte sur lequel nous allons
voter rappelle également un principe
fondamental le communautarisme n'a pas
sa place dans notre pays la finalité de
l'immigration et
l'intégration comme cela a été rappelé
par Madame la rapporteur les deux clés
les deux clés d'une intégration réussie
sont la maîtrise de la langue de la
langue française et le
travail la régularisation des étrangers
qui sont employés dans les métiers en
tension
traduit notre attachement à la valeur
travail il est important de sortir ces
personnes de toute
vulnérabilité tout en évitant tout appel
d'air cette mesure ne doit pas nous
empêcher de réfléchir aux causes
profondes de la pénurie de main d'OM
dans certains secteurs qui est évidente
et d'y apporter des solutions le texte
de la CMP dit également ce que nous ne
voulons pas les étrangers ne respectant
pas nos lois nos droits nos devoirs
essentiels et nos valeurs ne doivent pas
pouvoir rester dans notre pays de trop
nombreuses dispositions empêchaient le
réloignement tandis que les des délits
et des crimes continuaient d'être commis
par ces mêmes personnes nos concitoyens
ne peuvent plus l'accepter et il était
grand temps d'y
remédier la maîtrise des flux
migratoire ne pourra toutefois être tout
à fait efficace qu'à la condition d'être
être accompagné de règles européennes
efficaces la liberté de circulation au
sein de l'espace Schengen implique
nécessairement un contrôle strict aux
frontières de
l'Union l'ensemble des citoyens de
l'Union européenne nourrisse de fortes
attentes dans l'optique de l'adoption
prochaine du pacte asile et
migration l'Union européenne doit elle
aussi faire preuve de son efficacité et
ne pas prêter le flan aux critiques
comme tous les Européens nos concitoyens
ne peuvent plus accepter une immigration
subie la politique doit relever le défi
migratoire avec justice et fermeté sans
attendre le nouveau paquet législatif
européen le groupes les indépendants
votera en faveur de l'adoption de ce
texte merci la parole est à présent à
notre collègue Philippe boncarer pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues intervenant à la tribune
pour le groupe centriste et non pas
comme corapporteur il m'est permis de
commencer par des remerciements des
remerciements à Madame joura mon
corapporteur au président buffet
administrateurs et à tous ceux qui dans
les différents groupes et en particulier
les groupes de la majorité sénatoriale
nous ont accompagné pendant un temps
long que cela soit bien sûr en séance
que ça soit dans les travaux
préparatoires ou pour la période en CMP
un grand remerciement chers collègues
pour votre
[Applaudissements]
investissement vous dire ensuite que le
texte qui vous est soumis exprime que
pour nous il exprime nous le résumerions
ainsi une autorité régalienne forte dans
le respect de l'État de droit c'est donc
un texte ferme ceci vous a été exprimé
c'est aussi un texte c'est moins évoqué
qui marque un retour du Parlement dans
la définition de la politique migratoire
c'est le sens de l'article
1a c'est aussi un texte et qui marque
une volonté de compromis de la me à
l'article 4 bis ou au travail
d'intégration par le niveau linguistique
nous avons démontré notre capacité à
trouver des compromis et à dégager des
solutions je voulais ensuite vous dire
que c'est un texte qui exprime la
solidité de la majorité sénatoriale je
ne suis pas celui qui a vocation à
m'exprimer à ce titre mais quand même je
voulais vous dire chers collègues que le
travail qui a été mené en commun
nous a permis de dégager un premier
compromis qui n'était pas acquis au sein
de notre majorité sénatoriale en
particulier vous l'avez tous en tête sur
le CAD bis nous l'avons fait cela nous a
permis d'adopter un texte et que chacun
s'est approprié c'est assez remarquable
de voir comment toute la majorité
c'est'est finalement approprié le texte
issu de nos travaux et nous avons pu
mener ensemble et je vous en remercie
monsieur le président retill un deuxième
compromis qui était pour le moins pas
évident avec la majorité présidentielle
c'est un exercice qui était difficile
mais qui je crois qui a été réussi et
qui a été réussi au service d'un
parlement qui fonctionne parce que c'est
ça l'élément essentiel le Sénat par les
positions qu'il a adopté qu'il a porté
qu'il a réussi à construire a permis
d'éviter un vide
institutionnel quelle aurait été la
situation si nous n'avions pas pu voter
un texte si l'Assemblée nationale
n'avait pas pu voter un texte c'était
une situation qui mettait effectivement
en cause la stabilité de nos
institutions et ça je crois que nos
concitoyens ne l'auraient pas
[Applaudissements]
accepter vous avez fait ce que vous
deviez faire au service de l'intérêt
général je vrais terminer par le débat
politique puisque à l'évidence ce n'est
plus un sujet technique mais bien un
sujet politique et répondre aux
critiques qui ont été exprimées par la
gauche en vous disant que chacun sera
jugé sur ses idées et sur ses résultats
nous vous avons observé chers collègues
pendant une semaine en séance avant et
après vous n'avez pas approuvé vous
n'avez pas approuvé une mesure qui
porterait orientation encadrement
régulation je ne sais trop quoi
concernant les flux migratoires et vous
n'avez pas manqué une mesure qui
pourrait quelque part
désarmer notre outil régalien dans la
gestion des flux migratoires et dans la
défense de nos frontières il nous a
quand même permis de vous dire que dans
un pays il y a l'obligation de lui
donner les moyens d'égraisser sa
souveraineté et je terminerai par la
question
et je terminerai par la question du
rassemblement national qui obsède
effectivement les esprits en vous disant
que les centristes sont les adversaires
politiques du rassemblement
national nous l'exprimons la paille et
la poutre vous cherchez la paille dans
nos regards regardez la poutre dans le
vôre notre sujet ce
soir
les peurs et ses exploitations à nous
l'efficacité et la recherche de
solutions et j'en terminerai en vous
disant que ce qui fait aussi not
différence avec le RN c'est que nous
croyons à l'État de droit et que
l'autorité régalienne va pour nous avec
le respect de l'État de droit merci
detion merci chers
collèges la parole est à notre cègue
guoch pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire pour 5
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madames messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous sommes
arrivés au bout du cheminement
constitutionnel ou anticonstitutionnel
d'ailleurs on verra de ce texte reste le
passage à l'Assemblée nationale tout à
l'heure à tout seigneur tout honneur ce
texte est une victoire de la majorité
sénatoriale qui a fait plier le
gouvernement et a fait adopter son texte
dans les grandes lignes cela marque donc
l'officialisation de son intégration
définitive à la majorité gouvernementale
LR et LR sont des alliés non de
circonstances mais de
[Applaudissements]
fait depuis le votre du RDPI sur le
texte au Sénat d'ailleurs tout semblait
dit cette loi d'affichage est
regrettable et dangereuse nombre de ces
mesures sont totalement étrangères au
texte initial et tout l'aspect
d'intégration a été sacrifié pour une
victoire politicienne à la pyus ce texte
a échappé à ses auteurs et ce depuis le
mois de février monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur o notre Assemblée a pu
l'étudier en commission c'est bien un
texte dicté par la majorité sénatoriale
qui est sorti des discussions de la CMP
je dis discussion mais les métant
d'employés lors de cette réunion n'avent
rien de Digne suspension immédiate
suspension répété réunion de couloir
réunion avec l'exécutif à matigon à
l'Élysée tant plus que restraint entre
la conclusion de la CMP sa discussion
dans notre assemblée comme au bon vieux
temps oserisje dire des textes d'urgence
sanitaire
sommes surtout arrivés au bout de la
logique présidentielle du quoi qu'il en
coûte un texte aussi éloigné de ses
premières annonces mais un texte un
texte puisqu'il fallait un texte c'était
la cantation du président de la
République l'enjeu est trop important
pour la nation pour faire de la
politique politicienne c'est le ministre
de l'Intérieur Gérald daranin qui le dit
sur cette loi je suis favorable à ce
qu'un compromis intelligent soit trouvé
au service de l'intérêt général c'est ce
qu'avait dit vendredi le président
quôa d'immigration d'élit de solidarité
préférence nationale pour les
allocations familiales délit de séjour
irrégulier majoration des frais
d'inscription universitaire caution pour
les étrangers pour les étudiants
étrangers hors Union Européenne
restriction de l'accès à la nationalité
par le droit du sol l'imitation du
regroupement familial et G passe et le
gouvernement clame un équilibre avec
d'autres mesur
lesquelles la victoire idéologique du
rassemblement national est plus forte
jour c'est par ces mots que Jordan
Bardella a qualifié les résultats des
tractations de la CMP notre groupe le
constate et le déplore ce texte est un
pas de trop celui qui a aussi le plus de
conséquences humèes et politique ce
n'est pas la peine de se cacher derrière
des mesures dites gentill l'aggravation
des peines pour les marchands de sommeil
quel étranger prendra le risque de
dénoncer le raquette qu'il subissent s'
il risque l'expulsion les mesures
d'interdiction des buurs dans les CR une
demande répétée de notre groupe et
d'autres suite à une dizaine de
condamnations de notre pays par la CEDH
plus qu'une avancée à saluer c'est un
retour à l'état de droit normal trop
tardif quand à la mesure phare
d'équilibre la régularisation de droit
pour les travailleurs dans les métiers
en tenstion elle n'existe plus elle a
vite été oubliée comme le ministre du
Travail Olivier dussamp disparu au champ
d'honneur de cette loi cette
régularisation de droit et la pièce
manquante de la intégration pré par le
titre de ce texte comment ne pas vouloir
permettre à des personnes qui
travaillent qui veulent s'intégrer de
s'extirper de la peur permanente du
contrôle de l'éloignement d'un nouvel
exordre personne ne peut être
complètement intégré même après des
années avec cette peur permanente
intégré par le travail c'est aussi
régularisé par le travail et que dire du
discours culpabilisant demandant un
texte inventre pour se donner les moyens
de protéger les Français outre son
d'aspect d's et abant assimilant
l'immigration un danger dont il faut
protéger les Français c'est une fable
rien je dis rien dans ce texte de permet
l'amélioration des otf auquel le
gouvernement a si attaché annonçant
arriver à 100 %
d'exécution rien dans la diminution des
droits et des protections ne constitue
non plus une plus grande garantie
d'exécution d'une mesure d'éloignement
vous le savez cette hypocrisie cache mal
votre vision de l'immigration une vision
de l'étranger dangereux calculateur et
profiteur la politisation outranière de
la question migratoire est un piège qui
ne profite à personne ou alors à qui
cette collusion avec la droite pour
reprendre des idées et des slogans de la
droite extrême et et de l'extrême droite
est inédite et indigne nous sommes les
seuls à avoir pu imposer ce texte à
déclaré ricti dans tact notre groupe
dénonce tant les métants d'employés que
le fond de ce texte nous vrons contre ce
texte avec force et convictions et nous
appelons l'ensemble des parlementaires
du centre et de droite à peser la
réalité du texte final qui nous est
proposé avec leur conviction intime et
leur engagement politique comme commence
à le faire de nombreux députés de ces
partis et de nombreux
ministres la parole est à
[Musique]
présent à Monsieur Yan brossa pour le
groupe communiste républiain citoyen
écologiste kanaki pour 5
minutes
monsieur le monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je ne
m'étendrai pas sur les conditions pour
le moins chaotique dans lesquels nous
discutons de ce texte condition
chaotique alors même que la commission
mixte paritaire vient de s'achever alors
même que plusieurs ministres du
gouvernement annoncent l'intention de
démissionner alors même que plusieurs
députés de la majorité annonc qu'ils
voteront contre ce texte alors même
monsieur le ministre que vous nous dites
vous-même que plusieurs des mesures qui
sont contenues dans ce projet de loi
sont contraires à notre Constitution ce
qui n'est pas rien quand
même monsieur le ministre souvenons-nous
de ce que vous nous disiez il y a
quelques mois vous nous disiez nous
voulons être gentils avec les gentils et
méchants avec les méchants il manquait
manifestement une précision un détail un
codicile qui avait quand même son
importance
c'est que au fond à vos yeux aux yeux
des républicains aux yeux de l'extrême
droite le seul fait d'être étranger Vous
range dans la catégorie des méchants
parce que c'est cela la réalité parce
que c'est cela la
réalité vous pouvez vous pouvez
protester mais sinon comment comprendre
comment comprendre qu'un texte qui nous
est présenté au départ comme un moyen de
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
qu'un texte qui nous est présenté comme
un moyen de lutter contre les
délinquants sans papier finit par
s'attaquer aux prestations sociales des
étrangers en situation
régulière comment comprendre comment
justifier que dans ce texte qui est
censé lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière Vous allez vous en prendre
aux allocations familiales à laap à la
loocation de rentrée scolaire d'enfants
y compris français qui ont pour seul
tort d'être né de parents étrangers
voilà la réalité de votre
texte vous nous avez vous nous avez au
départ vendu un texte
d'intégration un texte d'intégration
disiez-vous c'est tout c'est tout sauf
un texte d'intégration c'est un texte de
stigmatisation et d'exclusion c'est un
texte de discrimination et c'est un
texte surtout qui accroîtra la pauvreté
sur le territoire français parce que
privé d'allocation familiale des
familles privé de prestations sociales
des familles c'est accroître la
précarité dans un pays qui compte déjà
excuser du peu c'est aussi votre bilan
10 millions de pauvres 4 millions de
Français mal logés 2 millions de
Français qui fréquentent l'aide
alimentaire c'est à croire que cela ne
vous suffit pas et vous allez encore
aggraver cette situation et dans ces
conditions dans ces conditions n'est pas
très surprenant il n'y a que vous qui
paraissez surpris que l'extrême droite
vote avec vous sur ce texte que vous
vous retrouviez aujourd'hui main dans la
main dans une nouvelle majorité
Renaissance LR rassemblement national
voilà la conséquence des concessions que
vous avez faites depuis plusieurs
semaines à la droite et à l'extrême
droite alors dans ces conditions dans
ces conditions quels arguments vous
reste-t-ilargument que vous répétez
matin midi et soir c'est ce que veulent
les Français curieusement cet argument
vous l'aviez oublié pendant le mouvement
des retraites alors même que vous avez
imposé aux Français un texte qu'il
rejetait par million dans les rues et en
se mettant en
grève et vous oubliez vous oubliez quand
même un peu vite vos propos lénifiant
entre les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle lorsque le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron allait
mendier les voix des électeurs de gauche
au nom de la défense des valeurs de la
République pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite et le résultat c'est
qu'on a élu Emmanuel Macron on n'a pas
voté pour l'extrême droite et on se
retrouve avec le programme de l'extrême
droite et avec la préférence nationale
dans la loi de la
République alors il est bien évident il
est bien évident que chacune chacun dans
ce contexte là doit mesurer la
responsabilité qui est la sienne la
question qui était posée la semaine
dernière c'était qui vote avec qui avec
cette fameuse motion de rejet à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui le
sujet ça n'est pas qui vote avec qui
c'est d'abord qui vote quoi et qui prend
la responsabilité notamment du côté des
macronistes de voter pour des mesures
qui vont dans le sens de ce que
proposait le Front national dans les
années 80 une chose est sûre ne nous
faites pas croire que vous avez des
principes ne nous faites pas croire que
vous avez des valeurs ne nous faites pas
croire que vous avez une colonne
vertébrale vous n'avez que
l'opportunisme pour guide et nous
voterons par c'est qu'en contre ce
texte mes chers collègues conformément à
l'article 42 aléa 12 du règlement je
vais mettre au voix l'ensemble du projet
de loi dans la rédaction résultant du
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire je suis saisi de trois
demandes de scrutin publ émanant du
groupe les républiques
du groupe écologie solidarité territoire
ainsi que du groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républiquain le scrutin est donc
ouvert il est 20h11 nous sommes en
direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre le résultat de ce vote sur les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire qui était réunis jusqu'à cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale se
députés 7 sénateurs qui sont parvenus à
un accord sur le j dois immigration
première étape donc qui va être sans
doute franchie sans peu de suspense dans
les prochaines secondes puisque le
droite de la droite et le centre devrai
voter ici au Sénat les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire le le plus
compliqué viendra ensuite hein vers
21h30 avec l'examen de ces mêmes
conclusions de la CMP à l'Assemblée
nationale mais vous avez entendu à la
tribune les sénateurs de la droite et du
centre qui ont dit bien le fait qu'il
validait tout ce qui était sorti de la
Commission mixpitaire de la CMP et que
effectivement maintenant et bien sans
problème
ces sénateurs de la droite et du centre
pouvaient voter les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritire il y a donc un
scrutin public qui va intervenir dans
quelques secondes vous allez pouvoir
voir comme cela la cartographie du vote
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat mais donc je
vous le disais sans grande surprise les
LR les centristes vont voter pour la
gauche va voter contre mais la majorité
étant ici à la Chambre haute favorable à
la droite et le centre les conclusions
de la commission mix paritaire vont
pouvoir être adoptées dans quelques
secondes quelques quelques minutes le
temps que tout le monde vote avec un
bulletin électronique dans l'enceinte de
la chambre haute et depuis 19h vous avez
pu suivre les explications de vote et
les la discussion générale autour de ces
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire je vous le rappelle cette
commission mixte paritaire qui était
réunie depuis 17h hier à l'Assemblée
Nationale 7 député 7 sénateur et qui ont
réussi à trouver un accord dans
l'après-midi sur les conclusions à
apporter au projet de loi immigration et
un texte qui ressemble à prendre à la
version du Sénat vous allez pouvoir
avoir la cartographie exacte du vote
c'est parti pour les résultats du
scrutin votant 340 exprimé
328 pour 214 contre 114 le Sénat a
adopté le projet de
loi mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21 45 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi visant à renforcer la
lutte contre les dérives sectaires la
séance est
suspendue voilà vous venez de le vivre
en direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
la première étape est franchie dans la
lecture des conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire puisque le Sénat vient
d'adopter ses conclusions de la SCMP je
vous le rappelle cet après-midi 7ette
députés et 7 sénateurs sont parvenus à
un accord sur les conclusions de ce
projet de loi immigration avec un texte
qui ressemble à prendre à celui voté le
14 novembre dernier lorsque le Sénat
examinait ce projet de loi immigration
c'est donc la première étape qui est
franchie pour ce projet de loi
immigration le plus compliqué reste à
faire dans les prochaines heures dans 1h
et quart exactement puisque'à 21h30
maintenant que les conclusions de cette
CMP sont voté par l'Assemblée nationale
et bien le texte voté par le Sénat le
texte par maintenant à l'Assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs il y a une
information qui trouble les députés de
la majorité depuis plusieurs heures
c'est le fait que Marine Le Pen appelle
à voter le texte qui sort de cette CMP
le ministre de l'Intérieur en a parlé
lors de la discussion générale écouter
un extrait de ce qu'a dit géralman à la
tribune le RN ici a voté contre aucune
disposition n'a été négociée avec eux
ils sont contre les
quotass chers collègues s'il vous plaî
ils sont contre les quotas ils sont
contre les régularisation ils sont
contre la fin des mineurs dans les
centres de rétention administratif ils
sont contre les passeports salent ils
sont contre les mesures sur
l'hébergement ils sont contre les
mesures qui concernent les
étudiants ils sont contre l'intégralité
des dispositions puisqu'ils ont connu à
trois exceptions près des votes contre
en commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de l'anupes regardez les
choses et soyez bourjoueurs il y a un
accord politique qui ne satisfait
personne un accord qui ne satisfait
personne totalement mais qui permet à
chacune et à chacun de se retrouver sur
l'essentiel la protection des Français
voilà première réaction en direct sur
Public Sénat à ce vote de la CMP par la
chambre haute du Parlement avec vous
François Noë buffet bonsoir vous êtes le
président LR de la commission des Lois
du Sénat un mot c'était attendu pe
supens la première étape est passée pour
ce texte issu de la CMP oui
incestablement il y avait pas de
d'inquiétude pour le vote de ses
conclusions devant le Sénat puisque nous
avions déjà voté la largement le texte
que celui qui sort de la commission mix
paritaire est à 90 % le nôtre quand je
dis le nôtre c'est celui de la majorité
sénatoriale naturellement adopté le 14
novembre dernier adopté le 14 novemb der
é d'abord ici au Sénat donc c'est une
étape de plus nous attendons maintenant
que l'Assemblée nationale se prononce
pour qu'enf ce texte puisse trouver sa
promulgation et son évidemment sa mise
en place on a vu Gérald haranin à
l'instant dans l'extrait répondre au
fait que le RN allait voter ce projet de
loi immigration parce queussi Marine Le
Pen appelle à voter ce texte qui ressort
de la CMP elle a dit tout à l'heure à
l'Assemblée nationale on peut se réjouir
d'une victoire idéologique du
rassemblement national et effectivement
elle a parlé notamment de la priorité
nationale qui rentre dans la loi
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de de ce
qui se joue autour du fait que le RN se
rallie à ce texte le rassemblement
national Madame Le Pen tente à holdup
euh il ne faut pas qu'elle le réussisse
il n'ont absolument rien fait dans ce
texte ça n'est pas leur texte mais ils
essayent d'en récupérer les fruits
chaque fois qu'il y a eu des textes
importants sur les sujets
régalien elle n'a pas franchi l'obstacle
donc là il se trouve qu'après avoir
critiqué ce texte pendant de nombreux
mois de nombreuses semaines et avoir du
pique pendre elle vient au secours de la
victoire c'est juste le signe d'une
grande faiblesse de mon point de vue et
cet argument sur le fond la priorité
nationale qui rentrerait dans la loi
absolument faux c'est absolument faux il
suffit les allocations par exemple qui
ne seront pas verersé de la même façon à
des
étrangers français ça c'est pas ça du
tout on a conditionné un certain nombre
de prestations qui sont non contributif
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres mais
dans le reste du texte il faut bien
regarder que la question est au
contraire de mieux traiter les migrants
qui viennent sur le territoire et de ne
pas et de pouvoir se donner les
conditions de cette intégration dans les
les meilleurs c'est ça l'enjeu faut pas
raconter l'histoire et puis c'est le
fait de dire la France choisit sa
politique migratoire dont acte mais tous
les pays du monde le font nous ne le
faisions pas jusqu'à maintenant nous
allons le faire mais en aucun cas il
s'agit de privilégier les uns pour les
autres il s'agit simplement de fixer les
conditions et quand on est sur le
territoire national et qu'on respecte à
la fois les de la République et qu'on se
comporte très très bien on fait partie
de la communauté nationale avec grand
plaisir dans ce cadre comment comprendre
cette hésitation de la part de député
Renaissance ou modem qui hésite à voter
le texte sorti par la CMP c'est ce qu'on
va voir dans une heure 10 à l'Assemblée
nationale notamment votre et bien
équivalent à l'Assemblée nationale Sacha
alier qui est le président de la
commission des lois et qui est
Renaissance qui a dit vouloir voter
contre mais il faut qu'il se ressaisisse
ce texte est aussi le leur c'est celui
de leur majorité c'est celui que nous
avons construit avec eux pendant la
discussion sur cette CMP donc il faut
pas qu'il se laisse impressionner par la
tentative de Hold Up de Madame Le Pen
assumons notre travail assumons notre
vision portonsla mais nous ne nous
comportons pas en fonction de ce que dit
ce que fait ou ce que ne fait pas Madame
Le Pen c'est le seul moyen de s'en
sortir peut-être que ces députés
voulaient cet article 3 qui s'est
transformé en article 4 bis avec des
revalor avec des régularisations de
travailleurs sans papier dans des M en
tenstion on comprend avec l'article qui
sort de la CMP il y a pas grandchose qui
change au contraire c'est même peut-être
plus compliqué encore pour une personne
qui va demander un titre de séjour dans
ses métiers entention non je suis en
désaccord c'est pas plus compliqué je
trouve que la procédure est simple elle
permet simplement à l'état de contrôler
la réalité du travail et de préserver de
préserver à la fois la personne qui
demande la régularisation et de
préserver en même temps et de vérifier
que l'employeur n'est pas un employeur
voyou voilà c'est quand même intéressant
sur le fond et ça ne ferme aucune porte
à personne j'ai une dernière question
question comment est-ce qu'on comprend
cette réunion à l'Élysée avec les chefs
de fil de la majorité et les ministres
concernés vous y voyez une crise vous au
sein de la macronie il est pas normal
quand vous avez des responsables de
votre parti politique qui laissent
entendre qu'il pas qu'ils ne vont pas
voter un texte alors qu'ils ont
travaillé dessus que le Président de la
République et la première ministre essae
de trouver des des explications essae de
remettre un peu d'ordre et je veux dire
ça me scandalise pas je trouve ça plutôt
normal et bien merci merci François Noël
buffet pour cette réponse au micro de
public sén nous on va écouter Patrick
canner la gauche très remontée contre
les conclusions cette CMP on en parle
juste après avec un sénateur communiste
bonne soirée par deux fois Emmanuel
Macron est arrivé au pouvoir car nous
car nous étions nombreux à espérer qu'il
fasse barrage à l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui le même Emmanuel Macron
amène les idées d'extrême droite au
pouvoir je
m'adresse je m'adresse aux
parlementaires qui de bonne foi on cru
en même temps du président de la
République ouvrez les yeux en 2027
allez-vous assumer d'avoir donné corps
aux pires excès de l'extrême droite
assumerez-vous d'avoir gravé la
préférence nationale dans le marbre de
la loi assumerez-vous d'avoir privé les
étrangers en situation régulière ainsi
que leurs enfants de moyens de
subsistance pendant plusieurs années
assumerez-vous d'avoir mis à terre les
principes de la nationalité
assumerez-vous d'avoir imposé aux
étudiants des conditions inatteignable
pour rejoindre nos universités
assumerez-vous d'avoir réduit les
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
à de simple variable d'ajustement
assumerez-vous de n'avoir pas fermé la
porte à la remise en cause de l'aide
médicale d'État les dispositions que j'
AZ voté depuis hier soir sont une
insulte à nos lumières allez une
deuxième réaction au au micro de Public
Sénat bonsoir et BR vous êtes sénateur
PCF de Paris porte-parole du Parti
communiste français je vous redonne ce
chiffre pour 214 contre 114 le Sénat a
adopté les conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire auquel à laquelle vous
apparteniez d'ailleurs hein vous avez
siégé depuis hier à l'Assemblée
Nationale 7 députés et 7 sénateurs une
réaction à ce vote on imagine la gauche
forcément déçue évidemment nous sommes
déçus cela dit on attend de voir ce que
donnera le vote à l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai quand même bon espoir qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale il y ait des
députés macronistes qui soi pris d'un
sursaut républicain et qui refuse de
voter ce texte qui de fait inscrit la
préférence nationale dans la loi
française en contradiction avec tout ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron avait annoncé quand
il est devenu président de la République
face au RN les alr s'en défendent aussi
he de cette question de la préférence
nationale en quoi est-ce que vous le
dites il y a matériellement pas
d'ambigué une préférence nationale dans
les conclusions de cette CMP ce texte
proetration il n'y a aucune espèce
d'ambiguïé on le voit en l'occurrence
que prévoit ce texte c'est que des
étrangers en situation régulière sur le
sol français ai besoin d'attendre 5 ans
avant de pouvoir toucher des prestations
sociales ça concerne ne travaille pas
s'il ne travaille pas mais enfin c'est
le cas d'un certain nombre de personnes
et qui pour autant n'ont rien fait de
mal qui justifie qu'ils ne puisse pas
bénéficier d'APL d'allocation familiale
ou d'allocation de de rentrée Scola on
peut d'ailleurs avoir des enfants
français qui ont des parents étrangers
et qui de fait se retrouvent privés
d'une allocation de rentrée scolaire du
fait de cette loi monsieur brossa à la
droite dit que c'est ce que veut
l'opinion française que les sondages
veulent disent que les Français veulent
plus voilà des mesures plus à droite sur
ces questions d'immigration qu'est-ce
que vous leur répondez sur cet argument-
là c'est vraiment l'argument de ceux qui
n'en ont pas pas ça n'est pas un
argument de fond d'ailleurs je note que
pendant le mouvement des retraites les
mêmes se faisaient fort d'aller contre
l'opinion publique en expliquant qu'ils
étaient courageux parce qu'ils
n'obéissaient pas au sondage et
aujourd'hui les mêmes nous expliquent
qu'il faut faire ce que disent les
sondages j'ajoute d'ailleurs que si on
avait raisonné comme ça on naurait
jamais supprimé la peine de mort et
c'est précisément le courage de
responsable politique parfois d'aller
contre le vent ambiant surtout qu'en ce
moment le vent est plutôt mauvais et
d'avoir le le courage effectivement de
tenir bon sur des principes qui sont des
principes républicain vous avez commencé
à en parler il y a effectivement des
figures de renaissance des chefs de fil
de ce parti des partis de la macroni
comme aussi le président du groupe modem
à l'Assemblée nationale qui ont annoncé
qu'ils vont voter contre dans 1h et 7
minutes lorsque l'examen arrivera à
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez bon
espoir vous avez fait des calculs vous à
gauche sur ce qui pourrait manquer comme
boie à Renaissance en tout cas je
souhaite ardemment que ce texte soit
rejeté ou du moins si le président de la
République en a conscience qu'il retire
ce ce texte et qu'il ne le soumette pas
qu'il ne soit que ce texte ne soit pas
soumis au vote à l'Assemblée
nationale en tout cas je pense qu'il est
toujours temps de se raviser et que en
l'occurrence ce qui se passait
extrêmement grave et que ellisabeth
borne va rentrer dans l'histoire comme
la première ministre qui a fait entrer
la préférence nationale dans la loi
française et ça n'est pas rien et donc
il leur reste encore un peu de temps
pour se raviser et pour mesurer ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire j'avais
une dernière question cela concerne une
déclaration de Gérald Darmanin
concernant les mesures qui sont dans les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire et qui donc viennent d'être
adoptées par le Sénat il a parlé de
mesures qui sont manifestement contraire
à la Constitution il a dit le Conseil
constitutionnel fera son office mais la
politique ce n'est pas d'être juriste
avant les juristes il évoque des mesures
qui viennent du texte du Sénat et qui
donc pourrait être contraire à la
Constitution qu'est-ce que ça vous
évoque c'est quand même lunaire d'avoir
un ministre de l'Intérieur qui présente
un texte de loi explique toutes les
raisons pour lesquelles il y est
favorable toutes les raisons pour
lesquelles il faut le voter et qui admet
que plusieurs des mesures qui sont
présentes dedans sont en réalité
contraires à la Constitution ce qui
n'est quand même pas rien et donc je
pense que tout cela traduit une forme
d'amateurisme du gouvernement qui a
avancé au fond les yeux bandés depuis le
départ sur ce projet de loi et qui se
retrouve avec un tracte du Front
National et bien merci merci y pour
cette réaction en direct et justement on
va écouter ce qu'a dit Gérald Darmanin
sur cette question des atteintes à la
Constitution dans le texte sorti de la
commission mix paritaire on écoute mise
à l'intérieur
bien sûr il y a des questions encore
autour de ce texte chacun c'est je veux
le dire ici monsieur le président de la
commission des lois Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs c'est pas
faire un jour au Sénat et nous en avons
parlé librement bien sûr dans cet
hémicycle les débats en font fois des
mesures sont manifestement et clairement
contraire à la
Constitution le travail du Conseil
constitutionnel fera son office mais la
politique ce n'est pas être juriste
avant les juristes la politique est
d'élaborer des normes et de constater si
elles sont ou pas d'après nous conformes
et oui des questions se posent sur un
certain nombre de disposition qui
pourrait être soit non conventionnelle
soit peu constitutionnelle mais laissons
le Conseil constitutionnel faire son
affaire je veux dire ici qu'en tant que
ministreintérieur et des autres maires
j'appliquerai bien évidemment non
seulement la lettre de la loi qui sera
promulguée par le Président de la
République et par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais également l'esprit
avec lequel nous avons travaillé tous
ensemble
voilà il est 20h26 si vous nous
rejoignez sur l'antenne Public Sénat le
Sénat qui a adopté les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire pour en
parler j'accueille ici Corine
naraassigin bonsoir madame Narassiguin
vous êtes sénatrice PS de s Sand et vous
étiez membre depuis hier de cette CMP
qui était réuni à l'Assemblée nationale
déjà un mot sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre Géral d'manin qui évoque des
points du texte qui seraient non
conforme à la Constitution que ça vous
évoque oui ils le savent depuis le début
en réalité depuis très précisément saz
il y il y en a pas mal qui sont
notamment notamment ceux qui touchent à
la C de la nationalité mais aussi pas
mal de Cell qui touchent au au
regroupement
familial mais ça c'est un choix
politique délibéré qu'ils font de
valider parce qu'ils voulit absolument
un accord et donc ils se repose sur le
Conseil constitutionnel pour retirer ses
mesures ils pensent qu'ils ont réussi un
coup politique en en obtenant grâce à
cela un accord politique avec le
rassemblement national mais ce qu'ils
font en fait c'est donner une victoire
culturelle totale aux idées du
rassemblement national pourquoi une
victoire culturelle en quoi est-ce que
vous voyez une victoire culturelle
totale c'est quoi exactement dans le
texte que par parce que en acceptant de
faire voter ces mesures tout en sachant
qu'elles ne sont pas constitutionnelles
c'est donner un blanin politique c'est
dire que ces mesures sur le fond sont
acceptables même si elles ne sont pas
constitutionnelles et donc ça va laisser
la porte ouverte maintenant pour que la
droite extrémisé et l'extrême droite
réclame des changements constitutionnels
on l'a appris tout à l'heure Marine Le
Pen qui a vé le texte qui sort de la CMP
on peut se réjouire d'une victoire
idéologique du rassemblement national là
encore oui qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
cette réaction à chaud de Marine Le Pen
juste après le vote c'est un excellent
résumé de ce qui s'est passé euh
Emmanuel Macron a cru ellisabeth borne
Gérald dermanin ont cru que ils faisait
eux un coup politique en réussissant à
faire à à obtenir un accord sur cette
commission mixpitaire à obtenir un texte
qui soit qui est maintenant qui va être
maintenant voté par le Parlement encore
que l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas
encore fait euh mais euh mais en réalité
ce qu'il se passe là c'est la
capitulation totale de renaissance aux
idées de l'extrême droite portée
maintenant par la droite qui se qui
s'appelle encore républicaine mais qui
n'en a plus que le nom madame n sigin il
nous reste une minute d'interview est-ce
que vous vous adressez à l'aile gauche
de renaissance voire même plus loin le
modem et cetera c'est à eux que revient
dans 1 heure peut-être la solution à
l'équation vous le pensez vous à gauche
oui il c'est le seul le le seul recours
qui nous reste c'est de compter sur ceux
qui sont encore attachés au principe de
not République ceux qui sont encore
humanistes et qui qui se qui tiennent
aux valeurs sur lesquelles à partir
desquelles ils ont été élus le mandat
qu'on leur a donné de faire barrage à
l'extrême droite et on espère que ils
seront suffisamment nombreux à voter
contre ce texte avec la gauche et les
ministres qui mettent aussi leur
démission Vous avez eu cette information
SEP ministres qui pourrait démissionneré
qui en en fait part s'il n'y a pas
effectivement oui alors c'est une bonne
chose que ça ça tangue un peu peut-être
que ça va faire réfléchir le
gouvernement on l'espère mais c'est
important là c'est un moment crucial
c'est vraiment un moment de bascule pour
la République et bien merci merci Corine
nartigin pour cette réaction au micro de
Public Sénat et la suite maintenant
c'est à 21h30 ce sera à suivre sur LCP
Assemblée Nationale nos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale collègues de la
Chaîne parlementaire qui vont vous faire
vivre dans une heure le vote des
conclusions de cette CMP maintenant par
la Chambre basse du Parlement très belle
suite des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]